Are you good at watching the holiday movies, the cartoons? I do because it's nostalgic, it makes me feel like where I put my onesie on, you know, with the feet, the whole, the pajamas. Yeah. Do you have a little, do you have the little, the button sort of window that drops in the back for poops? Don't beat around the bush. What are you trying to say? Do you have a back flap or do you have to? Yeah, but that's not my jeans. You're talking about my pajamas. Have you watched any of the holiday videos or movies? Not yet, but I'm going to.
你会看那些节日电影、动画片吗？我会，因为这很有怀旧感，让我想起我穿的那种连体睡衣，你知道的，带脚套的那种，整套的睡衣。是啊。你有没有那种，那种后面可以打开用来拉屎的小翻盖？别拐弯抹角的。你想说什么？你是有一个后翻盖，还是得？对，但那不是我的牛仔裤。你在说我的睡衣呢。你看过什么节日视频或电影吗？还没有，但我打算看。
It's going to be so exciting. Do you want to come over and watch them? Yeah, you came over last time. I guess we've got to come over to your place this time. Yeah, tip for tat. Tip for tat. Yeah. Splitety Splat.
那肯定超有意思。你想过来一起看吗？对啊，上回是你过来的。我猜这次轮到我们去你那儿了。对，礼尚往来。礼尚往来。对。扑通一声。
Welcome to a new episode. Smart less. Smart. Smart. Oh, my God. I'm so sorry. Jesus Christ, Sean. Fucking hell, Sean.
欢迎收看新一期节目。SmartLess。Smart。天哪。真是对不起。天哪，肖恩。他妈的见鬼，肖恩。
This is fucking bullshit. It wasn't on the, it wasn't on my calendar. Whoa, that's our fault. Yeah, don't say it like it's our fault. Who's in control of your calendar? Is it Nick the prick? Yeah. Did you get a deal on Nick?
这他妈太扯了。这不在，这不在我的日历上。哇，那是我们的错。对，别说得好像是我们的错一样。谁在管理你的日历？是那个混蛋尼克吗？对。你从尼克那儿捞到什么好处了吗？
By the way, Sean, he says fucking Nick. He didn't even know who Nick was. I mean, Nick for years has just been. We literally said, did we call Nick? And he goes, what's a Nick? Who's Nick? No, he said, what's a Nick? Yeah. What's a Nick?
顺便说一句，肖恩，他说的是他妈的尼克。他甚至不知道尼克是谁。我是说，尼克这些年一直就是。我们刚才 literalmente 问了，我们给尼克打电话了吗？然后他说，尼克是什么？尼克是谁？不，他说，尼克是什么？对。尼克是什么？
Oh, God. Like a discount assistant? We were about to call Cedars because we thought, have you checked the paddle waiting room for pounds? That's the worst feeling in the world. This guy's like, I'm like, what are you talking about? Okay, Will, let's take a couple of, oh, sorry, Will, do you want to finish you on that? Yeah. Okay.
哦，天哪。就像一个打折助理？我们正准备给西达斯医院打电话，因为我们在想，你查过扑克候诊室有没有人昏倒吗？那是世上最糟糕的感觉。这家伙就像是，我心想，你在胡说八道什么？好吧，威尔，让我们来点，哦，抱歉，威尔，你想把话说完吗？好。好吧。
Fucking Will Arnett, this guy. Wait, how are you guys? No, no. No, not yet. You already did that? You already did that? Let's take a guess of what we interrupted in Sean's life. What was going on?
他妈的威尔·阿奈特，这家伙。等等，你们俩怎么样？不，不。不，还没。你刚才不是做过了吗？你刚才不是做过了吗？我们来猜猜我们打断了肖恩生活中的什么事。当时在发生什么？
What were you doing? Spaghetti. No. Sorry, well, no, it's first thing in the morning, so that seemed like the most likely. He was turning the Pop-Tart over in the oven. I'm going to tell you right now, the honest guy truth,
你在干什么？意大利面。不。抱歉，威尔，不，这可是大清早，所以那听起来最有可能。他正在烤箱里翻转烤牛角面包。我马上就告诉你，说实话，
cast out sleeping. Okay. Because you got up too early. Shurning butter, a surprise guest is guest. Our surprise guest is real lippy. By the way, since you've been away, Sean, our surprise guest has been very active in the chat, which has been fun.
没在睡觉。好吧。因为你起得太早了。在搅黄油，有个惊喜嘉宾是嘉宾。我们的惊喜嘉宾话可真多。顺便说一句，肖恩，你不在的这段时间里，我们的惊喜嘉宾在聊天区里一直很活跃，这挺有意思的。
All right, good. I'm a big Olivia Munn fan and a fun lady. Yeah, okay. Okay, do you want to guess? No, but let's get back to Shawnee. So what happened? So how was your sleep?
好吧，挺好。我是奥立薇娅·穆恩的超级粉丝，她是个有趣的女士。好吧，行。好吧，你想猜猜吗？不想，但我们还是说回肖尼吧。所以怎么回事？所以你睡得怎么样？
What was your sleep? I got up in three. And then I wrote, and then I had the script that I had to write notes on. So I spent like three or four hours rereading it, rereading it, rereading it, and writing notes on it and stuff like that.
你睡眠怎么样？我3点钟起来的。然后我写了点东西，接着我有个剧本得写点笔记。所以我花了三四个小时反复读它，反复读它，反复读它，并在上面写笔记之类的。
And then I was like, oh, God, I got to go back to sleep. And then I, Scott was like, hey, you have a smart list. I'm like, what? And I jumped out of bed. You should smell my bird. breath.
然后我就想，天哪，我得回去睡觉了。然后我，斯科特就说，嘿，你有个SmartLess要录。我说，什么？然后我从床上跳了起来。你应该闻闻我嘴里的鸟气。
Oh, I'm good. Oh. Hey, so what's the process when we're done here? Nick gets what, a phone call or you want an in-person? Yeah, no. I'm definitely going to ask what happened. No, I, yeah, that's it. And my niece is here with her friends.
哦，不用了。哦。嘿，那我们这儿录完之后的流程是什么？尼克会怎么样，打个电话还是你想见个面？对，不。我绝对要问问发生了什么。不，我，对，就是这样。而且我侄女和她的朋友们在这儿。
So there's five girls staying in the house. Oh my God, it's there. So we're up late. Let's bring them in and have them smell your breath. Can we do that? So wait, this is the daughter. of who this is my brother dennis's daughter alice and i remember her name because it rhymes with niece oh that's a big deal that you remember the name of your niece yeah hey jason this is not a road
所以屋里住了五个女孩。天哪，她们在那儿。所以我们昨晚很晚才睡。把她们叫进来闻闻你的口气怎么样？我们能这样做吗？等等，这是谁的女儿？这是我弟弟丹尼斯的女儿爱丽丝，我记得她的名字是因为它跟“侄女（niece）”押韵哦，你能记住你侄女的名字这可真了不起啊。对，嘿，杰森，这不是你想踏上的
you want to go down right sorry um yeah hey so how old is elise um she's just turned 24 she just turned 24 take this sharpness out of your voice yeah i know he's so mad at me but he won't show it she's having a five person sleepover at uncle sean's house yeah yeah it's It's fun. Yeah. Did they get, did they climb into a bottle of something last night? Yes, they did, yeah. These girls.
路啊，对不起，嗯，对，嘿，爱丽丝多大了？嗯，她刚满24岁，她刚满24岁。把语气里的尖锐收一收吧。对，我知道他生我的气，但他不会表现出来。她正在肖恩叔叔家开五人睡衣派对呢。对，对。这挺有意思的。对。她们昨天晚上喝了点什么吗？是的，她们喝了，对。这些女孩。
These girls? They're really funny, though, but, you know, they're, like, in the middle of dinner last night. Like, they'll say the most random things. Are they crazy? They're crazy. I'm going to tell you something. Right in the middle of, we were talking about politics or drinking or something. And her friend, Taylor goes, um.
这些女孩？不过她们真的很有趣，但是，你知道的，就在昨晚吃晚饭的时候。她们会说一些最随机的话。她们疯了吗？她们太疯狂了。我告诉你们一件事。正当我们聊着政治或者喝酒之类的话题时。她的朋友泰勒说，嗯。
Oh, Taylor. That's probably taste. You don't, don't get me started on Taylor at a dinner. Was she there? Taylor at a dinner with politics? She must have... She goes, in the middle of the thing, she goes, oh my God, you guys,
哦，泰勒。那可能就是品味。你别，别让我一谈到泰勒就停不下来。她当时在那儿吗？在聊政治的饭局上有泰勒？她一定……她说，正说着呢，她突然说，天哪，你们大家，
did you hear Jesse Eisenberg is going to give away one of his kidneys to a stranger? I mean, that's unbelievable. By the way, that's the best part, that's the whole story of... And then she goes, oh my God, you guys, he's so nice.
你们听说杰西·艾森伯格要把自己的一个肾捐给一个陌生人吗？我的天，这太不可思议了。顺便说一句，这才是最精彩的部分，这整个故事的……然后她说，天哪，你们大家，他太好了。
By the way, I didn't know Jesse Eisenberg was giving away a kidney to a stranger. Hang on a second. Let's get back to Taylor's comment. I mean, and that's it. Was she wearing that cute thing that, what was that? Hey, so wait, so Jesse, I don't, I don't believe for one second that Jesse Eisenberg is giving away a kidney to a stranger. Yeah, that's not just some sort of, I didn't, it's in the news.
顺便说一句，我不知道杰西·艾森伯格要把一个肾捐给陌生人。等一下。我们回到泰勒的评论上。我是说，就这样。她当时穿着那件可爱的衣服吗，那是什么？嘿，等等，所以杰西，我不，我一秒钟都不相信杰西·艾森伯格会把一个肾捐给一个陌生人。对，那不只是某种，我不知道，新闻上就是这么说的。
Really? Yeah, it was in the news. And they have that, and they go, I didn't know. You guys, oh my God, Ed Sharon didn't use the phone. And then Elis goes, oh, he's so mysterious. And then I'm like. And then I'm like, they all really talk like that. And like, what?
真的吗？对，新闻上就是这么说的。他们有那个，然后他们说，我不知道。你们大家，天哪，艾德·希兰不用手机。然后爱丽丝说，哦，他太神秘了。然后我就。然后我就，她们真的全都那样说话。然后就，什么？
This is really happening. Where are they from? Chicago, Glenn Ellen. So they all flew in. Well, they all know, now one lives in New York, but they all live in the Chicagoland area and they all decided to fly in for her birthday. It was nice. It's fun.
这真的在发生。她们是哪里人？芝加哥，格伦埃林。所以她们都是坐飞机来的。好吧，她们都知道，现在一个住在纽约，但她们都住在芝加哥地区，然后她们都决定坐飞机来给她过生日。这挺好的。挺有意思的。
It's nice of you to host them. But Jason, this is what people do for family and this is what people do. It's selfless. Her uncle is rich and famous and lives in Hollywood, and so they're going to go out there and stay in his mansion.
你招待她们真是太好了。但是杰森，这就是人们为家人所做的事，这也是人们所做的事。这是无私的。她的叔叔又富有又出名，住在好莱坞，所以她们要跑去那儿住进他的豪宅。
That makes sense. What part of that do you not get? For how long? Are these strangers going to be in your house? It's his niece. They are going to be here for two or three more days. How long have they been there already? They're total of five days.
这说得通。这里面有哪部分你搞不懂？待多久？这些陌生人要在你家待多久？这是他的侄女。她们还要在这里待两三天。她们已经在那儿待多久了？总共五天。
That is a long day. Do you know the other girls' names? Yes. Taylor, Ainsley, Lily. Oh, shoot. And the new one. This is fun. Wait.
那可真够长的。你知道其他女孩的名字吗？知道。泰勒、安斯利、莉莉。哦，糟了。还有新来的那个。这挺好玩的。等等。
And Alondra. Alondra. Alondra. Catherine and Julie are surprised guests just threw in the show. I was close. What did she, what did the guests say?
还有阿兰德拉。阿兰德拉。阿兰德拉。凯瑟琳和朱莉，这是节目里突然多出来的惊喜嘉宾。我差一点就猜到了。她说什么了，那个嘉宾说什么了？
Julie and Julie, I was close. I was close. Oh my God, all right. Let's get to, who is this person? This is the most fun guest. Sean, I'm really excited that we're catching you in this. This is the rawest we've ever seen you.
朱莉和朱莉，我差一点。我差一点。天哪，好吧。我们来看看，这个人是谁？这是最有趣的嘉宾。肖恩，我真的很高兴能在这个状态下采访你。这是我们见过你最真实的一次。
I'm a nervous because I, yeah. No, I know. You are nervous because you just feel you're out of sorts. You're just waking up. You're raw. and I haven't seen you this raw since fill in the blank so
我有点紧张因为我，对。我知道。你很紧张，因为你觉得自己状态不对。你刚醒来。你还很生疏。而且自从上次填空以来，我就没见过你这么生疏了
no that was the name of the bar they had to close it down for health reasons but fill in the blank by the way gross title yeah are you guys going to meet it
不，那是那家酒吧的名字，他们因为卫生原因被迫关门了，不过顺便说一句，填空这个恶心的名字，对，你们要去见
fill in the black later our our guest our guest our guest has been active in the film business for many years dare I say
填空吗，稍后我们，我们的嘉宾，我们的嘉宾，我们的嘉宾在电影界活跃了很多年，我敢说
say most of his life and not just adult life most of his life life so Jason this is going to be somebody that you can identify with this is Kurt Russell but this is somebody who's been doing it for so long and who reached such incredible heights
大半辈子，而且不仅是成年后的大半辈子，是大半辈子，所以杰森，这将是一个你能感同身受的人，这就是库尔特·拉塞尔，但这是一个入行很久、并且达到了如此惊人高度的人
of fame as a young person and has continued to work throughout it's been incredible started in films like Rocket Gibraltar born in the 4th of July then movies started to have more success in bigger roles and in movies like Uncle Buck, Jacob's Ladder,
作为一个年轻人就享有盛名，并且一直工作到现在，这真是不可思议，从出演《直布罗陀火箭》、《生于七月四日》这样的电影开始，后来电影在更大的角色中获得了更多成功，出演了《巴克叔叔》、《异世浮生》，
and then absolutely went through the stratosphere with Home Alone, Home Alone, too, Rich and Rich, and then, it's McCauley. It's McCulley. Welcome to the show. You were on my list as well. Oh my God, this is so cool. He's appropriately dressed in Smartless PJs.
然后凭借《小鬼当家》、《小鬼当家2》、《财神当家》直接冲上平流层，然后，是麦考利。是麦考利。欢迎来到节目。你也在我的名单上。天哪，这太酷了。他穿着得体的SmartLess睡衣。
Oh, yes, of course, yes. McCauley, I'm so sorry I was late. So many apologies. I'm never. Yeah, it's too late for that. He just, no, I mean, just Taylor, when Taylor gets going, and then just forget it.
哦，是的，当然，是的。麦考利，非常抱歉我迟到了。一万个抱歉。我从来不。对，现在说这个太迟了。他刚，不，我是说，只要泰勒一开讲，然后就别管了。
You know what I mean? Just let her off the leash, I swear. I don't know if you heard about Ed Shearin, but it's so mysterious. Macaulay, Colkin. My Godly. Where are we finding you today? I'm in Los Angeles, yeah.
你知道我的意思吗？就让她脱缰吧，我发誓。我不知道你有没有听说过艾德·希兰的事，但太神秘了。麦考利·卡尔金。我的天啊。今天我们在哪里找到你？我在洛杉矶，对。
Yeah? Oh, what part? I live in Toluca Lake. Oh, Loua Lake. I've done a lot of time there. I like it. Make it sound like a prison, you know. No.
是吗？哦，哪个区？我住在托卢卡湖。哦，卢卡湖。我在那儿待过很长时间。我喜欢那儿。你把它说得像个监狱一样，你知道的。不。
I spend it a lot of time there. Yeah, I love it there. They got one of the greatest. golf clubs in all of America there at Lakeside. Yeah. Do you golf, McColley? No, no, but I'm investing in a golf cart. We'll put it that way.
我在那儿待了很长时间。对，我很喜欢那儿。那里有全美最棒的乡村俱乐部之一，湖畔俱乐部。对。你打高尔夫吗，麦考利？不，不，不过我正在投资一辆高尔夫球车。这么说吧。
So you can tool around the neighborhood? Yeah, pretty much. For real? Yeah, you know, because you've got a Jones. You know, everyone has a golf cart, so you don't have Jones, you know. By the way, you know what's interesting, Sean? I was going to say, McCauley, what's interesting is that you're an Angelino now, perhaps. You live in Los Angeles, but you're a New Yorker, and yet you played a character who's so closely
这样你就可以在社区里兜风了？对，差不多吧。真的吗？对，你知道的，因为你有个琼斯。你知道，每个人都有一辆高尔夫球车，所以你不能没有琼斯，你知道的。顺便说一句，你知道有趣的是什么吗，肖恩？我正想说，麦考利，有趣的是你现在可能成了一个洛杉矶人。你住在洛杉矶，但你是个纽约客，然而你演了一个与芝加哥紧密相连的角色
identified with Chicago. Yes. So you've kind of really covered the whole country. You belong to America. I mean, do you say that? That's well put, yes. But I love how a New Yorker is like a Chicago, like, you know, they love me there. I swear to God, I do gangboosters over there.
是的。所以你几乎跑遍了整个国家。你属于美国。我是说，你这么认为吗？这话讲得好，是的。但我喜欢一个纽约客就像个芝加哥人一样，你知道的，他们在那儿很喜欢我。我发誓，我在那边很受欢迎。
Do you? In Chicago? In Chicago? Yeah, Sean, hang on, Sean. Hang on, Sean, hang on. She said Chicago. Sean's also done some time there. Yeah.
是吗？在芝加哥？在芝加哥？对，肖恩，等等，肖恩。等等，肖恩，等等。她说的是芝加哥。肖恩也在那儿待过一段时间。对。
Every time we mentioned, yeah, go ahead. Do you want to just get it over with? And then we can move on to other things. Yeah. So when I was a kid. and I was in high school, John Hughes was making all of his movies in, as you know, in and around Chicago, right?
每次我们提到，对，说吧。你想就此跳过吗？然后我们可以谈谈别的。对。所以当我还是个孩子的时候，
Yes, of course you remember. He's very aware. I was there. So it was wild to grow, I've said this before, it was wild to grow up in the town where he was making the movies and then when I'm in high school, those movies came out about high school.
我在读高中，正如你所知的，约翰·休斯当时所有的电影都是在芝加哥及周边拍摄的，对吧？是的，你当然记得。他非常清楚。我当时就在那儿。所以，在拍摄这些电影的小镇上长大，这感觉很疯狂，我已经说过好几次了，这感觉很疯狂，然后当我在读高中时，那些关于高中生活的电影上映了。
So it was all encompassed John Hughes all the time all around Chicago show. Sean, who did you identify with? Is it Ducky? By the way, I got called Ducky all the time. All the time. I did because I dressed like him and everything. Yeah.
所以这完全包罗了约翰·休斯的所有元素，到处都是芝加哥，肖恩。肖恩，你认同谁？是达基吗？顺便说一句，我老是被叫达基。一直都是。我就是因为我穿得跟他一模一样。对。
Did you ever see them shooting around the neighborhood, Sean? No, but no, but Lucas, you know, was filmed in my high school. And if you remember that movie, Lucas, anybody? Yes, yes. Charlie Sheen and, yeah, yeah. Charlie Sheen, yeah, we're known to writer's first film. That was a great little movie, actually, Lucas. I like that film.
肖恩，你见过他们在社区周围拍戏吗？没有，但是没有，不过《终极ing》你知道的，是在我的高中拍的。如果你还记得那部电影的话，《终极ing》，有人记得吗？记得，记得。查理·辛和，对，对。查理·辛，对，我们知道是编剧的第一部电影。其实那是一部很棒的小电影，《终极ing》。我很喜欢那部电影。
I was an extra. I was like 14 years old. Anyway, who cared? Did you sit in a background holding? You're all on a foldout? Were you late to that? And that little boy. Did you think through that?
我当过群演。我当时大概14岁。总之，谁在乎呢。你坐在背景里当道具吗？你都折叠着坐吗？你当时迟到了吗？还有那个小男孩。你考虑过那个吗？
That nobody wanted. That's right. That's right. Jason, what I thought you were going to say is, are you excited for the release? because we're going to talk about it later of Zootopia 2. Yes, very much so. Yes. Me and Brenda are taking a bite of the forbidden fruit. We're playing brother and sister. Miao. Wow. Yeah. Oh, boy. Wait, who is? I mean, my lady. Yeah. Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm going to be at the premiere. Now, which, what animal is your character?
那是谁都不想要的。没错。没错。杰森，我以为你想说的是，你期待上映吗？因为我们待会儿要聊《疯狂动物城2》。对，非常期待。对。我和布兰达在偷吃禁果。我们演兄妹。喵。哇。对。哦，天哪。等等，谁是？我是说，我的女伴。对。哦，对，对，我要去首映礼。那么，你的角色是什么动物？
We are playing cats. That meow is literal, yeah. Jason, what are you? Jason, you're a fox, right? Thanks, man. You had that one in the chamber. McCauley, you're in Zootopia and Jason, you didn't know which character he was. To be honest, had no idea McCauley was in it.
我们演猫。那个“喵”是字面意思，对。杰森，你是什么？杰森，你是狐狸，对吧？谢啦，老兄。你早把这句揣在枪膛里了。麦考利，你在《疯狂动物城》里，而杰森却不知道你是哪个角色。说实话，我根本不知道麦考利在里面。
Yeah, yeah. No, are you kidding? This is animation. Yeah, they don't let anybody know anything. Willie, tell them I'm wrong. I honestly don't even know what the film is about. I didn't know what the first film was about. I didn't know until I saw it.
对，对。不，你在开玩笑吧？这是动画片。对，他们什么都不告诉任何人。威尔，告诉他们我错了。老实说，我甚至不知道这部电影是关于什么的。我连第一部是关于什么的都不知道。我直到看的时候才知道。
I have had those moments, this is so embarrassing. But like Jason, where somebody goes, hey, you run into someone, they go, hey, we're doing the thing. And you go, no way. By the way, this is when it's done. This is not going into it. It's typical of animation.
我有过那种时刻，这太尴尬了。但就像杰森，当有人说，嘿，我们在拍那个东西。然后你说，不会吧。顺便说一句，这是做完之后的事。这不是在制作过程中。这是动画的典型情况。
It's done. You just go in and you kind of, yeah. You record your scenes, you know, a la carte over the period of a couple of years. Had you done a bunch of animated stuff, McCauley, before? Yeah, yeah. Back in the early 90s, like everyone else, I had a Saturday morning cartoon. You know, I remember they gave one to, I remember they gave one to Roseanne Bard, John Candy had Camp Candy. They had a Bobby's World, Howie Mandel.
做完了。你只要进去，然后差不多，对。你录制你的场景，你知道的，像单点一样，在几年内完成。麦考利，你以前做过很多动画方面的工作吗？对，对。早在90年代初，就像其他人一样，我有一部周六早晨动画片。你知道，我记得他们给过，我记得他们给罗斯anne·巴尔开过一部，约翰·坎迪有《坎迪营》。他们有《鲍比的世界》，豪威·曼德尔。
That's right. Louis Anderson had his own Saturday morning cartoon. That's right. Give it away, like, like, candy. Saturday morning cartoons, you guys, was everything for me when I was throwing up. Me too, me too, man. I love that. It was so, we're a little bit older than you were McCauley,
没错。路易·安德森有他自己的周六早晨动画片。没错。到处送，就像，就像糖果一样。伙计们，周六早晨的动画片对我小时候来说就是一切。我也是，我也是，老兄。我太喜欢了。那是如此，我们比你稍微年长一点，麦考利，
but you probably also remember that feeling of the Saturday morning cartoon. Oh, heck yeah, no, look forward to it. I'm raising my kids with like Saturday morning cartoons. Like, it's like, yeah, it's just on YouTube now, but like, yeah, it's a thing. Exactly, just on YouTube. And what was great about it back then was that we only, you only got it on Saturday. So it just wasn't available 24-7, so it felt really smooth. It was appointment television.
但你可能也还记得那种周六早晨看动画片的感觉。哦，天哪，不，非常期待。我用周六早晨动画片来抚养我的孩子。这就好像，是的，现在它只在YouTube上播，但就像，是的，这是一种文化。没错，就在YouTube上。那时候最棒的一点是，我们只有，你只有在周六才能看到。所以它不是24小时全天候播出的，感觉真的很特别。这是按时收看的电视节目。
Yeah, so certainly. Yeah, yeah. Wait, all right. So, Macaulay, we're going to roll it all the way back like we like to do. We're going to get right to the beginning because you did start, like I said, when you were, as everybody, a lot of people know, that you started very young acting. And not unlike our friend Jason Bateman. What was the age? What was the age at which you decided or you got you and your family decided like, I'm going to do this?
对，确实。对，对。等等，好吧。所以，麦考利，我们要像往常一样，把时间彻底倒回从头说起。我们要直奔起点，因为正如我所说，正如很多人所知，你很小就开始演戏了。这和我们的朋友杰森·贝特曼很像。那时候多大？你决定或者你和你家人决定“我要做这个”的时候你多大？
Was this predetermined, or were you... Did you seek it? What was the thing that started, that said, hey, I'm going to, we should do this? It was actually, it was my father. He was going to take my older brother and sister, and he was going to take, like, headshots of them in the park, and it was, and then my mom was kind of just like,
这是事先注定的，还是你……你是主动寻找的？是什么拉开了序幕，让你觉得，嘿，我应该，我们应该这么做？其实是我父亲。他打算带我哥哥姐姐去公园给他们拍定妆照，然后我妈妈就差不多说，
oh, just take Mac with you. Like, you know, I think she just wanted a break. And, yeah, I just started booking right away. I started out earning everyone else pretty fast. Wow. Through commercials and stuff, do you mean? You know, it was more, I did, like, Black Box Theater in Manhattan, and I got written up for that.
哦，把麦克也带上吧。你知道的，我觉得她只是想歇会儿。然后，对，我马上就开始接到戏了。我很快就开始比其他人赚得更多了。哇。你是说通过拍广告之类的吗？你知道，更多的是，我在曼哈顿演过黑匣子剧场，我还因此被写进报道里了。
And then, honestly, I just, I jumped pretty much straight to film. I did a couple of commercials here and there, but, like, literally out of the gate, it was Black Box Theater and then cinema. So, am I right, that Rocket Gibraltar was your first film? Yeah, yeah. That was actually Bert Lancaster is one of his last movies. Wow, that.
然后，老实说，我几乎直接跳到了电影圈。我零星拍过几个广告，但 literalmente 一出道，就是黑匣子剧场，然后就是电影。所以，我没记错的话，《直布罗陀火箭》是你的第一部电影？对，对。那其实是伯特·兰卡斯特的最后几部电影之一。哇，那。
They hired a bunch of New York stage actors, and I was a, you know, stage actor. And it was, like, who's like Bill Pullman, Patricia Clarkson. Spacey was in it and stuff like that. Uh-oh, yeah. I didn't... I was just saying, uh-oh. What was your... What was that life your first experience on a film set?
他们雇了一群纽约舞台剧演员，而我是一个，你知道的，舞台剧演员。里面有像比尔·普尔曼、帕特里夏·克拉克森这样的人。史派西也在里面之类的。噢噢，对。我没……我只是在说“噢噢”。你的……你第一次在电影片场是什么体验？
How old were you? Did you remember? I was six. Wow. Yeah, no, honestly, it was... I just knew whatever... Memorize your lines, don't look in the camera. You know, find your light, hit your marks, things like that.
你当时多大？你还记得吗？我六岁。哇。对，不，老实说，我就是……我只知道无论如何……记住你的台词，不要看镜头。你知道的，寻找你的光，踩准你的点，诸如此类的事情。
It was pretty straight forward for me. You know, but Sean's still trying to nail that down. No, but that's what blows my mind when young kids, yourself, and how do they know to do that? Like, there's so many kids that can't do that. Did your parents give you that? Yeah. I mean, yeah, pretty much, you know, like a, you know, when you're a kid, you're a fast learner.
对我来说挺直截了当的。你知道，不过肖恩还在努力搞懂这些。不，但这就是让我感到震惊的地方，当小孩子，比如你自己，他们怎么知道该怎么做？因为有那么多小孩做不到这一点。是你的父母教给你的吗？对。我是说，对，差不多吧，你知道的，就像一个，你知道的，当你是个孩子时，你学得很快。
And wasn't the draw, was the draw the same for you as it was for me? It was just like, basically, I get to skip school. That's all I was looking at. You know, as it went on, for me, as it went on, it was actually the opposite. Because I was always away, and I didn't like, and you have to remember, A lot of my work when I was, you know, pretty much when I was younger, I never worked with people my own age. I was always working with adults like that.
那吸引力，吸引力对你来说和我对你的一样吗？其实就是，基本上，我可以逃学了。这就是我当时看重的。你知道，随着时间推移，对我来说，随着时间推移，其实正好相反。因为我总是在外地，我不喜欢，而且你得记住，我小时候做的大多数工作，我从不跟同龄人一起工作。我总是和这样的大人们一起工作。
So, like, yeah. So if anything, I kind of had a yearning to, like, go to school, to, like, you know, have contemporaries and things like that. And did you ever? Yeah. Once I quit, I quit when I was 14. Yeah. Quit for, like, nearly a decade.
所以，就像，是的。所以如果有的话，我其实有一种渴望，想去上学，去，你知道的，有同龄人伴左右之类的。你后来有吗？有。我14岁时就不干了。对。不干了将近十年。
And, yeah, no, just, just went to school, went to high school, you know, fell in love, got, you know, got, you know, got, you know, got drunk for the first time, things like that. Yeah. What was that like? I mean, because you had, as I pointed out, we all know, you had incredible success. First of all, Uncle Buck, it's just an absolute gem of a film.
然后，对，不，就是，就是去上学，上高中，你知道的，坠入爱河，经历，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，第一次喝醉酒，诸如此类的事情。对。那种感觉怎么样？我是说，因为正如我指出的，我们都知道，你取得了难以置信的成功。首先，《巴克叔叔》，绝对是一部宝藏电影。
It holds up. I watch it like once a year. It kills me. You have great taste. And I know you were part of that John Candy documentary, too, about, right? Yeah, that was lovely. Yeah, no, it really was a good tribute to him. It really did him justice.
经得起时间考验。我差不多一年看一次。笑死我了。你很有品味。而且我知道你当时也参与了那个关于约翰·坎迪的纪录片，对吧？对，那很可爱。对，不，那确实是对他很好的致敬。真的没有辜负他。
They were actually trying to track me down for a while, and I just kind of kept on just going, yeah, I'll get around to it, and just never did. And finally, yeah, finally they tracked me down and on the carpet when they did the premiere. I talked to Colin Hanks. He was the one who directed it?
他们其实找了我好一阵子，我只是一直在敷衍说，行吧，我抽空看，但就一直没弄。最后，对，他们总算在首映礼的红毯上找到我了。我跟科林·汉克斯聊过。是他在执导吗？
And I said, who was harder to track down me or Bill Murray? He goes, you. He didn't even blink. Wow. Really? So what was John Candy like? Because I've always just, that guy to me is just such a giant.
我问他，我和比尔·默瑞哪个更难找？他说，你。他连眼睛都没眨一下。哇。真的吗？那约翰·坎迪是个什么样的人？因为在我眼里，这家伙一直是个巨人。
Yeah, no, he was sweet. He was very giving. You know, they always say don't work with kids or animals, you know, but he was actually really good with me. Yeah, he was very sweet. I did three films with him because he was also in Home Alone and also I had a brief part in Only the Lonely.
对，不，他很温柔。他非常慷慨。你知道，人们总是说不要跟小孩或动物一起工作，你知道的，但他对我和我合作得真的很好。对，他非常温柔。我跟他拍过三部电影，因为他还演了《小鬼当家》，而且我在《纯爱 A La Carte》里也有个小角色。
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Now, McCalley, when you took your 10-year hiatus, was there an expectation that your spot would be held for you in line? Or were you at that point where you were like, I don't really care if I come back to this industry? I was Dunskys. I was full, I was done.
哦，对。对。麦考利，当你隐退十年的那段时间里，有没有一种期待，觉得你的位置会一直为你留着？还是说你当时已经到了那种地步，觉得我根本不在乎会不会回到这个行业？我当时不干了。我彻底，我受够了。
Like, yeah, yeah. I was like, I hope you all made your money because there's no more coming from me. Yeah, I made my name, I made my mark, I made my fortune. Like, so I don't, you know, like, the only reason why I even, like, do it now is because I like to do it, you know, it's the, you know, it's a, what is it,
就像，对，对。我就觉得，我希望你们都已经赚够钱了，因为从我这儿再也捞不到钱了。对，我扬名立万了，我留下印记了，我赚够财富了。所以我不，你知道的，就像，我现在之所以还会去干，唯一的理由是我喜欢这么干，你知道的，这就是，你知道的，什么来着，
pay, pleasure, prestige. That's the only reason to do a gig. Technically, I'm retired right now. Like, I retire, and then if I find something I like, I unretired do that, and I immediately retire afterward. Every gig is my last. He just, Shod just acts like he's retired. He's not retired, but he just sleeps in.
片酬、乐趣、声望。这就是接工作的唯一理由。严格来说，我现在退休了。就像，我退休了，然后如果我发现喜欢的东西，我就复出干那个，干完之后马上又退休。每一份工作都是我的最后一份。他只是，肖恩只是装得像退休了一样。他才没退休呢，他只是爱睡懒觉。
He does whatever he wants. When you were not acting and you were going through high school and then hitting the college years, was there a thought to study a different industry? Was there an interest poll anywhere? Not necessarily. I was kind of just drifting around and try to figure out kind of what I wanted out of life and so forth.
他想干嘛就干嘛。当你不再演戏，经历高中和大学岁月时，有没有想过学习别的行业？有没有对其他什么地方产生兴趣？倒不一定。我当时只是随波逐流，试着弄清楚我对生活到底有什么诉求之类的。
I mean, listen, this was a calling that found me. I didn't find it. And so I wanted to explore that in a different kind of way. on my terms? Well, talk about that because I went through a very similar thing where it was just like, well, I'm young enough to really start over
我是说，听着，这是一份找上门来的召唤，不是我去找它的。所以我想用一种不同的方式去探索它，按我自己的条件来？
and at something that I can sort of drive a little bit more. I can have much more say in my longevity and my relevance and my access in any other career, any other occupation, any other industry. Did you want to do something else, J.B.? I did. I desperately wanted to do something
哦，聊聊这个吧，因为我也经历过非常相似的事情，当时就是，好吧，我还年轻，完全可以重新开始，而且是从事一份我能有更多掌控权的工作。我能对自己的职业寿命、相关度以及在任何其他职业、任何其他行业中的机会有更多的话语权。你当时想做点别的吗，J.B.？我想过。我极其渴望能做一门
that I could count on, that I wasn't so nervous about main maintaining employment in. And so, you know, I got another job before I ever fully went into, you know, studying something else. But was that, was that a part of your thinking at all, Macaulay? Was there, tell us about that, about just thinking about going forward and providing. I mean, I was in a position where I could just put my thumb up my butt and play video
我可以依靠的、不用为保住饭碗而那么焦虑的工作。所以，你知道的，在我完全投入去学习其他东西之前，我就已经找了另一份工作。但那是，那是你考虑过的一部分吗，麦考利？跟我们聊聊这个吧，关于向前看和谋生。我是说，我当时的处境是，我可以翘着二郎腿整天打电子
games all day long. Yeah, I could do anything I want. Yeah, and so... There was enough employment before you quit at 14 to cover you for the rest of your life? Indeed. Oh, great. Wow.
游戏。对，我想干嘛就干嘛。对，所以……在你14岁隐退之前赚的钱足够你花一辈子吗？确实。哦，太棒了哇。
That was not my case. But there was that... Maybe that Hogan's Family Bank? No, it wasn't enough. No, you did okay. I mean, you know, we were... I was spending too much. I was having fun, you know.
我可不是这样。但当时有那种……也许靠《欢乐家庭》的片酬？不，那不够。不，你干得挺好的。我是说，你知道的，我们当时……我花得太多了。我当时玩得很开心，你知道的。
On what? On just like basically, catching up. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So McCaulay, but you know, it's funny, you use the expression, you said, you know, there's no more money to be made off me or something like that, which I, which I wonder, like,
花在什么上？基本上就是，把以前错过的都补回来。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。所以麦考利，你知道，这很有趣，你用了这个词，你说，你知道的，再也无法从我身上捞到钱了或者类似这样的话，这让我觉得，
when you did quit and you were 14, was there a sense of like that, that you had, was there a sense of resentment towards people who had made money off you in a way? Wade? No, no. I mean, I got the lion's share of it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But it was also, it was kind of a rat race. Like, it was, I remember when I stopped having fun, I wanted to kind of, I wanted to take a break. And I said, I was getting really taxed. And, uh, and it's like, yeah, I just kind of want to do like a semester of school, you know, that kind of thing. And, um, I was not heard. And that was something that really affected me and affected my work and stuff like that. And then it was just like, oh, I'm on. on the hamster wheel and I can't get off. And so once I had some autonomy and some agency in my life, I grabbed it with both hands. But that's a big burden for a kid of 14.
当你14岁隐退的时候，有没有那种感觉，就是，你对那些曾经靠你赚钱的人产生了一种怨恨？哪种？没有，没有。我是说，我拿了大头。对，对，对。但这同时也是一种鼠目寸光的激烈竞争。就像，我记得当我不再觉得好玩时，我想休息一下。我说，我感觉压力太大了。然后，就像，我只是想去上个学期的学，你知道的，那种感觉。然后，我的意见没被听取。那是一件真正伤害了我、影响了我的工作之类的事情。然后就变成，哦，我上了
First of all, it's kind of a big realization for a kid of 14 to be able to actually listen to yourself and go, hey, this doesn't feel great and the people that I'm trusting, I'm trying to tell people this is how I feel and they're not necessarily recognizing that. there's got to be I can imagine I can only sort of try to imagine
仓鼠轮，根本停不下来。所以一旦我在生活中拥有了一些自主权和决定权，我便双双紧紧抓住了。但这对一个14岁的孩子来说是一个沉重的负担。首先，一个14岁的孩子能有这种觉悟，能够真正倾听自己的心声，说“嘿，这感觉不太好，而我信任的人，我正试图告诉大家我的感受，但他们并没有真正意识到这一点”，这本身就是一种很大的领悟。我可以想象，我只能试着想象
how I would feel if I felt like there must be a frustration in there a little bit I'm not by the way I'm not trying to push you into a position I'm just curious no no I mean I was definitely frustrated like yeah and it was again it was kind of just like yeah once I had the chance to get off it was like cool and I said I'll just figure it all out later
如果是我，我会是什么感觉，如果我觉得里面一定有很多挫折感的话。我不是，顺便说一句，我不是想把你推向某种立场，我只是好奇。没有，没有，我是说，我绝对感到很挫折，就像，是的，而且再次重申，就好像，一旦我有机会下来，我就觉得太酷了，我说我以后会把这一切都搞定的，
you know yeah I'll just that's kind of what I did you know and I imagine that were you like other child actors myself included Was it the inevitability of your parents being your manager? Was that the case in your life as well? Yeah, yeah. And I had a pretty acrimonious relationship with my father, famously so.
你知道，是的，我会的，我当时就是这么做的。而且我猜，你是不是也和其他童星一样——包括我在内——父母成为你的经纪人是无可避免的？你的生活也是这样吗？对，对。我和我父亲的关系相当恶劣，这是出了名的。
Oh, yeah. Yeah, and as soon as I was able to kind of push him out, like, yeah, just my quality of life on the day-to-day level definitely went up. Right, gotcha. Yeah, I had a very complicated relationship with that as well. Certainly, as you get older, in retrospect, it becomes even more complicated as you become a parent and you start to think about the decisions, that they make about being an employee in your life
哦，对。对，只要我一能把他推开，我的日常生活质量绝对就上升了。对，明白了。对，我对此也有非常复杂的感受。当然，随着年龄增长，回过头来看，当你自己成为父母，开始思考他们对你生活中作为打工人的决定时，这种感受会变得更加复杂。
and how that adjusts the dynamic of how you look at your parents as, you know, what should be sort of your North Star, the person that you follow, when instead they now create a dynamic where you're the boss at an age when you're kind of needing parental girls. Yeah, and that's where their bread is buttered, you know, yeah. Yeah, it's really complicated. But, you know, I think you look to be on the other side of that very healthily.
而且这如何调整了你看待父母的方式，他们本该是你的北极星、你追随的人，然而他们却制造了一种动态，让你在正需要父母引导的年纪当上了老板。对，因为那是他们赖以谋生的饭碗，你知道的，对。是的，这真的很复杂。但是，你知道的，我觉得你非常健康地走出了那一阴影。
I hope I am too. You pointed out before this idea, McCauley, I don't know if you had this, but this has always stuck with me, J.B., and I think about it from time to time. Truly, I do. That you, I remember you saying, you had to keep your grades up
希望我也是。麦考利，你之前指出了这个观点，我不知道你有没有这种感觉，但这一直在我的脑海里挥之不去，J.B.，我时不时还会想起它。真的，我是这么想的。你，我记得你说过，你必须保持好成绩
in order to keep working, right? That they're by law. Every six months, yeah. So there was a pressure to keep your grades up so that you could work so that you could pay the bills because you were the bedwinner, right? Yeah, every six months it was a grading period,
才能继续工作，对吧？法律规定是这样的。每六个月一次，对。所以有一种压力，必须保持好成绩，这样你才能工作，这样你才能付账单，因为你是家里唯一的经济支柱，对吧？对，每六个月是一个评定期，
or you had to maintain a C average, or you lose your work permit. And so whatever job you're on, you would be fired immediately. And so all the crew members go out of work, all the network gets upset. Fuck me. You know, like you're...
或者你必须保持C的平均分，否则你就会失去工作许可。无论你在哪个剧组，你都会立刻被解雇。所以所有的剧组成员都得失业，整个电视网都会不高兴。操。你知道的，就像你……
And you're a kid. Yeah. So midterms and finals, when you're doing a test that affects your grade by like 60 or 70%, it's just like earth-shattering pressure. Right. Did you have that,
而且你还是个孩子。对。所以期中和期末考试，当你面临一场决定你60%或70%成绩的考试时，那简直是天塌下来的压力。对。你有过那种，
did you experience that, McCorry? Not really. I was a fairly good student. And I had a pretty, a pretty great onset tutor and she, yeah,
你有过这种经历吗，麦考利？倒没有。我算是个相当不错的学生。而且我有一个相当、相当棒的现场家教，她，对，
she was very sympathetic to me and just when it came to like she could tell when I was tired or burn out or something like that
她非常同情我，每当她看出我很累或者精疲力竭之类的时候
if you're having trouble answering any questions you just whisper it to you. Yeah, no, I wasn't like that, it wasn't like that, you know.
如果你在回答任何问题时遇到麻烦，她就会直接悄悄告诉你。不，我不是那样的，没那么夸张，你知道的。
But yeah, she definitely, she definitely like would lay off me. Like she'd see me just keep me a wink if you don't know this one.
但她确实，她确实会放我一马。就像她会看到我，如果你不知道这个，她就给我使个眼色。
No, she'd like read me like the outsiders or something like that. Really? I'm going to read it to you could have to think.
不，她会读《局外人》或者类似的东西给我听。真的吗？我要读给你听，你必须思考。
Yeah. like that. Like, you know, yeah. Yeah, it was pretty great. You just rest your head against my shoulder. Where is this? Say, golden pony boy. Get over here.
诸如此类。就像，你知道，对。对，这挺棒的。你只要把头靠在我的肩膀上。这是哪儿？说，黄金小马男孩。过来这里。
Wow. That's hysterical. Well, I mean, by the way, so then what we're also not addressing is the fact, so you decide at 14, you're like, look, I need a break, I kind of want to shift gears here. I don't know if I want to do this anymore.
哇。太滑稽了。好吧，我是说，顺便说一句，我们接下来没有讨论的是，你14岁时决定，听着，我需要休息，我想换个档。我不知道我还想不想干这个了。
Huge shift. Compounded by the fact that you're about as famous a person there is on the planet at this point. Still, to this day. Until this day, of course. But I'm saying at 14. Yeah, it was a difficult, tricky waters
巨大的转变。再加上当时你大概是地球上名气最大的人之一。直到今天依然如此。直到今天，当然。但我是说在14岁的时候。对，那是很难、很棘手的水域，
to maneuver through and stuff like that because you don't necessarily have the actual or emotional vocabulary to really kind of maneuver through those waters. And I always kind of thought of myself as a peerless person. Like I couldn't turn left and right. Like, you know, like and go, oh, you're like me.
很难在其中游刃有余，因为你未必具备真正驾驭这些水域的实际或情感词汇。我一直觉得自己是个无双的人。就像我不能向左或向右看，就像，你知道的，然后说，哦，你跟我一样。
Like, you know, it was a very unique experience. Yeah. And so, yeah, you know, so, yeah, it was, you know, I kind of had to, like, you know, just figure it out on my own for a big chunk of it. Yeah, I was going to say, like, how have you adjusted, if at all, how you are in public going to anywhere? Like, do you feel like you have to kind of compromise yourself and go, God, here we go? I definitely have to gird myself, you know, for, you know, outings and so forth. Right. You know, I just set certain ground rules for myself.
就像，你知道的，那是一段非常独特的经历。所以，是的，你知道的，所以，是的，你知道的，我很大一部分时间只能靠自己摸索。对，我正想说，你如何调整自己在公众面前去任何地方的方式，如果有的话？比如，你是否觉得你不得不做出妥协，然后说，天哪，又来了？我确实得为外出之类的活动做好心理建设。对。你知道的，我只是给自己设定了一些基本规则。
Like, you know, just, yeah, like, don't approach me when I'm at the dinner table. I don't like that, you know. Don't approach me when I'm with my kids. Definitely don't follow me to the bathroom, you know, like, things like that. You know, yeah. And I just realized that I'm in charge of the social contract. I'm in charge of the interaction. Sean, what are you scratching off on what list?
比如，你知道，是的，当我在餐桌旁时不要接近我。我不喜欢那样，你知道的。当我跟孩子们在一起时不要接近我。绝对不要跟着我进洗手间，你知道的，诸如此类。你知道的，是的。而且我意识到我是社会契约的掌控者。我是互动的掌控者。肖恩，你在单子上划掉什么呢？
What are you doing? What are you talking about? Oh. No bathroom. Sean drops a lot of notes that say, please follow me to the bathroom. So then there you are, and now you take a decade off or whatever it was, a huge chunk of time, what's the moment where you go, I want to go back or you know, you kind of get to like the end of high school and you kind of just like, oh, what am I going to do with my life? You know, again, I could kind of do whatever I wanted. And, you know, there was that kind of thought where, like I said, this was something that found me. I didn't find it. And let me see, let me try this on. for size a little bit so I was about 20 or so
你在干什么？你在说什么？哦。没有洗手间。肖恩留下了很多写着“请跟着我进洗手间”的便签。所以，然后你在那儿，接着你息影了十年或者不管多久，好长一段时间，你什么时候会有这种想法，我想回去，或者你差不多到高中快结束的时候，你差不多就想，哦，我对我的生活要做什么？你知道的，再次重申，我差不多可以做任何我想做的事。而且，你知道，当时有那种想法，就像我说的，这是一件找上门来的召唤，不是我去找它的。让我看看，让我试穿一下
2021 I went to London did it did a play there for a year brought it back to the States that was fun it was a successful and then you know jumped in did party monster then I did save what play was it it was called Madame Melville was it at the barbecan the vaudeville theater of the Strand
看看合适不合适，所以我当时20岁左右，
sorry Jason had a question nothing was there was there ever a thought was there thought to go to college at all to study different career? Not necessarily, no. Like I said, I mean, unless I had, like, a focus on something, I didn't really see the point of it, like, just go get a degree in general.
20、21岁时我去了伦敦，在那儿演了一年的话剧，把它带回了美国，那挺好玩的，很成功，然后你知道的，加入了《怪兽派对》，然后我演了，那是部什么话剧？叫《梅尔维尔夫人》，是在巴比肯剧院还是斯特兰德的沃德维尔剧院？对不起，杰森有个问题，没什么，有没有想过，有没有想过去上大学去学别的职业？倒不一定，没有。就像我说的，我是说，除非我对某事有专注度，否则我真的看不出为了拿个综合学位去上学有什么意义。
Like, you know, if I wanted to be like, you know, wanted to study, like, English literature or something like that. Yeah, that would make sense. You know what I mean? But I didn't have that necessarily, that kind of bone in my body. So, yeah, I kind of just, although I did kind of, I semi-regrette because I remember visiting friends at college,
比如说，你知道，如果我想成为那种，你知道，想学英语文学或者类似专业的人。对，那倒也说得通。你知道我的意思吗？但我身上不一定有那种，那种基因。所以，对，我差不多就是，虽然我确实有点，我其实有点后悔，因为我记得我去大学探望朋友时，
I go, oh, it looks like fun. Right, right, right. But, again, it would have been, it would have been purely social, really. It's like, yeah, I'm paying all that money to be social with people. Was social life enough outside of college to pacify that curiosity? Yeah, no, definitely. You know, yeah. I've had good groups of friends and so forth.
我就想，哦，这看起来挺好玩的。对对对。但是，话说回来，那纯粹，纯粹就只是为了社交，真的。就像是，没错，我花那么多钱就是为了跟别人社交。大学之外的社交生活足以满足那种好奇心吗？对，不，绝对够。你知道，对。我有一群很好的朋友之类的。
You know, yeah. Oh, I thought you were, I thought, Jason, you were saying, did you party? Well, basically. I mean, I'm looking at my daughter at college right now and just like, it just looks like so much damn fun. I mean, I definitely had fun without college, but my God, the whole sort of, and then, because it's like this great counterbalance. So, like, once you kind of sober up and you get past your hangar and everything, you do want to kind of balance it with something.
你知道，对。哦，我还以为你是，我以为，杰森，你在说，你以前去过派对吗？嗯，基本上吧。我的意思是，我看着我女儿现在上大学，就觉得，这他妈看起来太好玩了。我的意思是，我没上大学确实也玩得很开心，但是天哪，那种整体的氛围，然后，因为这就像是一个很好的平衡器。所以，比如说，一旦你酒醒了，过了宿醉期什么的，你确实会想用某种东西来平衡一下。
I didn't have that opportunity. With college, you can go listen to some incredible professor, give a lecture on something, and you can kind of bathe yourself with something that's highbrow, you know, I don't know. It would have been a good, good thing for me. You're so wistful, you know. I know. All I had was Charlie Rose in New York Times
我当时没有那个机会。上了大学，你可以去听某个了不起的教授讲课，听关于某种主题的讲座，你可以让自己沐浴在那种高雅的氛围中，你知道，我不知道。那对我来说会是一件好事，一件很好的事。你真是多愁善感啊，你知道的。我懂。我当时在纽约只有查理·罗斯和《纽约时报》
To sort ofade myself Macaulay, did you ever guest star in a sitcom or anything? Yeah, it's funny. There was one long time ago, geez, I can't remember the name of it. Ah, you were Will and Grace. Yeah, I did an episode of Will and Grace. Yeah, that was great.
来陪伴自己。麦考利，你曾经在情景喜剧里客串过吗？对，挺逗的。很久以前有过一个，天哪，我都想不起名字了。啊，你演过《威尔与格蕾丝》。对，我拍过一集《威尔与格蕾丝》。对，挺棒的。
You were fantastic. Oh, thanks, yeah. No, I remember you were talking about how you're talking about Nancy Clemsky. Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah, you were like, I know Nancy and Anna. Wait, oh, that's right, because of... And you were like, you did an impersonation of her.
你演得太棒了。哦，谢谢，对。不，我记得你当时在说，你在说南希·克莱姆斯基。哦，对。对对对，你当时说，我认识南希和安娜。等等，哦，对哦，因为……然后你还说，你模仿了她。
I was like, that was spot on. I haven't seen her in like 15 years. But I was like, yeah, you pinged me. That's right. Of Anna's mom, Nancy. Wait, because you were in my girl. Yes, we were at my girl together. Yeah, and Anne and I grew up in Chicago.
我当时觉得，简直绝了。我有十五年没见她了。但我当时就想，对，你想起我来了。没错。安娜的妈妈，南希。等等，因为你演过《小女孩》。对，我们一起演过《小女孩》。对，安妮和我都是在芝加哥长大的。
Yeah, I don't know what. It's all. Everybody's connected as well. Yeah, it's a small town, really. You were great. You were great on the show. It was fun. Yeah, I mostly worked with Megan and stuff, but that was fun.
对，我不知道怎么说。总之。每个人都互相认识。对，说实话，这就是个小镇。你演得很好。你在剧里演得很好。挺好玩的。对，我主要跟梅根他们合作，不过挺有意思的。
Yeah. You know, yeah. To be fair, also, I didn't know what I was walking into. I'd never seen an episode in my whole life. That's fine, me neither. Yeah, yeah, exactly. These guys have any of them. So, so you take the break, you come back, you do theater, you come back to New York,
对。你知道，对。公平地说，我当时也不知道我要面对的是什么。我这辈子从来没看过那部剧。没关系，我也没有。对对，没错。这几个人谁都没看。所以，你休息了一段时间，然后回来，演了话剧，回到了纽约，
and then you do Party Monster. And I remember that was kind of like your big return. It was like a big Sundance hit, right? It was like a... Yeah, it was kind of what I wanted. You know, I was like, oh, I saw the... Oh, Sundance looks cool. I wanted to do some of the Sundancey and stuff, you know.
然后你演了《派对怪兽》。我记得那可以说是你的强势回归。那是一部圣丹斯的轰动之作，对吧？那是一部……对，那差不多就是我想要的。你知道，我当时就想，哦，我看到……哦，圣丹斯看起来挺酷的。我想拍点带点圣丹斯风格的东西，你知道的。
It was based on a true story. The book was really good. It was just like, yeah, like a... You know, it was something. kind of left of center kind of material and kind of, I didn't want to just jump into studio fair really. And did you feel, did you feel
它是根据真实故事改编的。那本书真的很棒。感觉就像，对，就像一个……你知道，那是一个有点剑走偏锋的题材，而且，我不想直接去演那种好莱坞大片。那你觉得，你觉得
satisfied once you did that? Not satisfied in terms of like I'm good forever, but did you feel like, okay, I'm doing the right thing here, I'm back, I'm kind of driving my own train here a little bit now. Yeah, definitely. It was nice to try those boots on for size. And yeah, and kind of
拍完之后觉得满足吗？不是那种从此以后就圆满了的满足，而是你觉得自己，好吧，我在这里做对了事，我回来了，现在我自己掌握着方向盘了。对，绝对是的。试穿这双靴子感觉挺不错的。而且，对，就
like again, having some, you know, autonomy, like I said, an agency where I was kind of like, oh, this is what I want. to do. And yeah, no, it was a ton of fun. You know, yeah, it was very different. Because I was doing all these, like, really expensive studio kind of gigs. And next thing you know, we're kind of guerrilla filming in Times Square,
像我说的，再次拥有了一些自主权，你知道，就像我说的，一种主动权，当时我就觉得，哦，这正是我想要做的。而且，对，不，真的超级好玩。你知道，对，这非常不同。因为我之前一直在拍那些，真的非常昂贵的好莱坞大制作。转眼间，我们就开始在时代广场进行游击式拍摄，
waiting for the police patrol to go by so that we could film and then, you know, got to wait again. And, like, you know, Seth Green is dressed like a pork chop. I'm wearing just nothing but, like, you know, just like a feather boa as an entire outfit. Yeah, it's great. Great movie. And it was.
等着巡逻警察过去，然后我们好开拍，接着，你知道，又得等。而且，你知道，塞斯·格林打扮得像个猪排。我身上除了羽毛Boa围巾之外什么都没穿，整套造型就只有这个。对，太棒了。好电影。而且确实是。
It was a great movie. What's the funny? What are you laughing at, Jason? I'm going to call it. I was wearing a feather ball. It's complete outfit. Sean's like, yeah, yeah. I love that movie.
那是一部好电影。有什么好笑的？你在笑什么，杰森？我要说出来了。我当时戴着一根羽毛围巾。那是整套造型。肖恩的表情就像是，对，对。我喜欢那部电影。
I do. I love that movie. Sean just woke up. Sean's very raw. He just woke up. Wait. So, wait, so Brenda, right? Is her name Brenda?
我是。我喜欢那部电影。肖恩刚醒。肖恩状态还很生猛。他刚醒。等等。所以，等等，所以布伦达，对吧？她叫布伦达吗？
Yeah, yeah, Brenda. Yeah, my lady. Yeah, as she, forgive me. That's your wife? Yeah, we're actually, we're unwed interracial couples. So, yeah, we check all the boxes when it comes to. Well, but wait, so then you haven't slept together. Yeah, oh yeah, well, I mean,
对，对，布伦达。对，我女朋友。对，她，原谅我。那是你太太？对，其实我们是，我们是未婚的跨种族情侣。所以，对，我们在各方面都符合条件。好吧，但是等等，那你们还没睡过觉。对，哦对，我的意思是，
Only twice, really, you know Wait a second, there goes heaven Oh, look at those kids Oh, my God Two boys, am I guessing right? I'm the maker of men Oh, wait, let me see it again, let me see it again No, you have to tap it again
其实也就两次吧，你知道的。等一下，天堂来了。哦，看看那些孩子。天哪。两个男孩，我猜得对吗？我是造人能手。哦，等等，让我再看一眼，让我再看一眼。不，你得再点一下。
Dark Yeah, oops, face ID Look at those things Oh, that's great I can't wear a double-bressed jacket Yeah, no, they're two boxy on me You ever try rocking a Mohawk too? Yeah, they're two boxy on me
黑屏。对，哎呀，面容ID。看看那些东西。哦，太棒了。我穿不了双排扣西装。对，不行，它们在我身上显得太方了。你试过留莫霍克发型吗？对，它们在我身上显得太方了。
All right, so where, when did you meet your baby mama? Yeah, yeah. We did a film together in Thailand. I went all the way to Thailand. He met a Thai girl from Sacramento. Nice. Wow. Yeah.
好吧，那么，你是什么时候、在哪里遇到你孩子的妈的？对，对。我们在泰国一起拍了一部电影。我大老远跑到泰国。他居然在萨克拉门托遇到一个泰国女孩。不错。哇。对。
Yeah, and we kind of met there. We didn't have any scenes together, but we had a lot of free time. Let's put it that way. Yeah, and I think, especially she was looking at, oh, this is going to be a fling. And I think we both were, like, fleeing, you know, yeah. And she's like, I never had a fling before. And, yeah, we got that. back to the States and we kept it going.
对，我们就在那里认识的。我们俩没有什么对手戏，但是有很多空闲时间。这么说吧。对，而且我觉得，尤其是她当时在想，哦，这只是一段露水情缘。我觉得我们俩当时其实都在逃避什么，你知道的，对。然后她说，我以前从来没有过露水情缘。然后，对，我们回到美国后，就把这段感情维持了下来。
And, you know, yeah. How long has that been? About eight and a half years now. Oh, wow. Very cool. Yeah. Yeah, we'll get married someday, you know. I mean, it's funny because she wanted me to propose.
然后，你知道，对。这维持多久了？大概八年半了吧。哦，哇。太酷了。对。对，我们总有一天会结婚的，你知道的。我的意思是，挺逗的，因为她以前一直想让我求婚。
She wanted to get married. And so finally I put a ring on it. And now she's in no hurry to get married. I'm like, wait a second. Is she engaged perpetually engaged? Yeah, it's been, she's about four years, almost on the doubt. We got engaged on Christmas of 2021. All right. Now, how do you like being a dad? I mean, it's considering the incredibly colorful childhood you had, are you enjoying having that role now?
她想结婚。所以最后我给她戴上了戒指。结果现在她一点也不急着结婚了。我就想，等一下。她这是处于无限期的订婚状态吗？对，已经，她大约有四年了，几乎分毫不差。我们在2021年的圣诞节订婚的。好吧。现在，你觉得当爸爸感觉怎么样？我是说，考虑到你度过的那个丰富多彩的童年，你现在享受扮演这个角色吗？
Yeah, yeah. No, I absolutely love it. You know, yeah. It's a little, it's, it was strange because it's, I didn't really have a lot of, I'm kind of reinventing the wheel. Let's put it that way. I didn't really have any good role models. So, you know, my father was a goddamn piece of work. Right. And it was completely untraditional, non-traditional. So it was scary. It was absolutely scary. Yeah. And, yeah, like I said, like my, you know, like what, like, what a proper family was.
对，对。不，我绝对超爱。你知道，对。这有点，这挺奇妙的，因为我其实没有太多，我可以说是在重新发明轮子。这么说吧。我其实没有什么好的榜样。所以，你知道，我父亲他妈的就是个奇葩。没错。而且那完全是非传统的，一点也不传统。所以这很吓人。绝对吓人。对。而且，对，就像我说的，就像我的，你知道，就像什么，像一个真正的家庭应该是什么样。
Right. Really, it was more refl, you know, it was like a, you know, growing pains or family ties or something like that. You know, like, yeah. Because I definitely did not have a conventional family. And how many of your siblings, sorry. third of seven kids. My mother did not have a family. She had a litter, a litter of Culkin's. Wow.
对。真的，其实更多的是反映，你知道，就像是一个，你知道的，成长的烦恼或者成长的天空之类的节目。你知道，就像是，对，因为我确实没有一个常规的家庭。你有多少个兄弟姐妹，抱歉。七个孩子里排行老三。我母亲建立的不是一个家庭。她生了一窝，生了一窝卡尔金。哇。
Wow. Seven. So are you, do you guys run a very then traditional house? Like, is there Sunday dinners and, yeah? Yeah, I mean, we definitely wear matching pajamas. That's cool. And, yeah, no, it's a, they have a more structured life than I did. Mine was kind of more freewheeling, kind of, you know, like a
哇。七个。所以你们，你们现在过的是非常传统的家庭生活吗？比如，会有周日家庭聚餐之类的吗？对，我的意思是，我们确实会穿亲子睡衣。挺酷的。而且，对，不，他们的生活比我更有规律。我的生活要更自由散漫一些，有点像那种，
It makes you want to be a better dad, right? Indeed, indeed. You know, again, that's that's the whole thing. I don't want the sins of my father being passed on to my kids. Right, right, right. So, yeah, I'm, you know, so yeah. And are you, so are you close to your family, your family of origin, like your, your siblings and?
这会让你想成为一个更好的爸爸，对吧？确实，确实。你知道，话说回来，这就是全部的意义所在。我可不想把我父亲犯下的罪孽传给我的孩子们。对，对，对。所以，对，我，你知道，所以，对。而且你是，所以你和你的原生家庭亲近吗，比如你的兄弟姐妹？
A little bit, I mean, yeah, I mean, I keep in touch, but they're, they're all East Coast. None of them have ever lived outside of New York City. I've lived all over the place and stuff, so I'm 3,000 miles away, so it's, I don't seem as often touch base, things like that, you know, Merry Christmas, every Thanksgiving. How many of them are performers, but I know that your, your brother, Cairn's an actor, of course. Yeah, no, I'm very proud of him. Between me and him, we have exactly one Oscar, yeah.
有一点，我的意思是，对，我的意思是，我跟他们保持联系，但他们都在东海岸。他们从来没有一个人离开过纽约市。我到处搬家生活，所以我离他们有三千里远，所以，我不那么经常和他们联系，基础沟通之类的，比如祝圣诞快乐，感恩节快乐。他们有多少人是表演者，我知道你弟弟基兰是个演员，当然。对，不，我为他感到非常骄傲。我和他加起来，我们正好有一座奥斯卡奖，对。
Ah, that's good. That's really good. And my brother, Rory, he works a lot, too. He actually works for me and Kieran combined. He's just doing a bunch of indies and stuff. He's always moving. Is it nice to be able to reach out to a sibling and discuss the oddities of this business?
啊，那挺好。那真的很好。我弟弟罗里，他也接很多戏。他接的戏其实比我和基兰加起来还要多。他一直在接拍各种独立电影之类的。他总是在奔波。能够向兄弟姐妹倾诉这个行业的古怪之处，这种感觉是不是挺好的？
I know I enjoy that sometimes with my sister. No, we don't really, honestly, we don't really talk shop. You know, like, yeah, we were kind of a, I mean, occasionally you kind of touch base on it kind of thing, but it's like, you know, like, you know, just because, like, you know, just because you're both mailmen doesn't mean you want to talk about the male, you know, that kind of thing. Is your wife still acting? Oh, yeah, no, she's, she, she's always swimming. She's always moving forward. She's on that show Running Point. She just finished season two last week.
我知道我有时很享受和我妹妹这样。不，我们其实不怎么，老实说，我们不怎么聊工作。你知道，就，对，我们基本上，我的意思是，偶尔你会聊聊这类事情，但这就好像是，你知道，就好像，你知道，仅仅因为你们俩都是邮递员，并不意味着你们就想讨论送信的事，你知道，就是那种感觉。你妻子还在演戏吗？哦，对，不，她，她一直在游泳。她一直在向前迈进。她在演那部叫《一锤定音》的剧。她上周刚拍完第二季。
Oh, wow. And she's, she's got, she's working on two films in January and March and stuff. Like, yeah, she books. She likes it. She likes the pursuit. I don't really like the pursuit. I like the work itself. She likes the whole package.
哦，哇。而且她，她有，她在一月和三月还有两部电影要拍之类的。没错，她片约不断。她喜欢这样。她喜欢那种追求的过程。我其实不太喜欢那个追求的过程。我喜欢工作本身。她喜欢整个流程。
She loves auditioning. I freaking hate it. Like things like that. Oh, me too. Yeah, yeah. So she's a bit of a masochist then, huh? Yes, yes, indeed. You know, but listen, God bless her because she knew what she wanted out of life.
她喜欢试镜。我他妈讨厌极了。类似这样的事情。哦，我也是。对，对。所以她其实有点受虐狂倾向，对吧？是的，是的，确实如此。你知道，不过听着，上帝保佑她，因为她清楚自己想要从生活中得到什么。
And she knew what to pursue and she pursues it to her fullest, which is very admirable. But, yeah, I, you know, for me, I'm kind of just, I'm kind of more of a, like, she's a shark. She has to keep swimming or she drowns. I'm more of a kind of a feeder fish. I kind of let things sieve for me kind of thing. Well, but Macaulay, you sound so, I don't mean to press you on this. I'm just purely curious because we come from some similar backgrounds.
她知道该追求什么，而且她会全力以赴地去追求，这非常令人钦佩。但是，对，我，你知道，对我来说，我其实更像是一个，她就像是一条鲨鱼。她必须不停地游，否则就会溺水。我更像是一条底层滤食鱼。我喜欢让东西自己顺水漂到我嘴边的那种。不过，麦考利，听起来你真的很，我不是非要逼问你。我只是纯粹好奇，因为我们有着相似的背景。
But I'm so in awe of your contentment. Like it seems like you, you know, I'll take it if it comes. If it doesn't, it doesn't. I'm not particularly obsessed or drawn to any one. particular thing there's no there's in other words are you do you have anything like i've got to get this done before i die uh not necessarily i mean at least when it comes to like my work and things like that uh it's like you know gosh i mean you know i practically just sometimes i used to do like general meetings like for a living kind of thing you know they want they want a silver bullet idea
但我对你的满足感感到无比惊叹。就好像你，你知道的，有就接着，没有就算了。我没有特别痴迷或执着于任何单一的特定事物，也就是说，没有什么事是你觉得“我死之前必须把这个搞定”的？倒也不一定，至少当涉及到我的工作之类的事情时……那就是，你知道，天哪，我的意思是，你知道，有时候我以前甚至会为了生计去开那种例行会议，你知道的，他们想要一个杀手锏般的创意。
you know what i mean they want to go i want to play a doctor but a kooky one you know i want to play a quarterback you know sure i don't really have that i let things kind of come to me it's the um The old, you know, it was the case before the Supreme Court. They were like a, they tried to define what pornography was. And pornography, the definition of it, according to the Supreme Court, is I know it when I see it. It's literally what he said, you know, yeah. So I'll know it when I see it. I treat it like pornography, pretty much is what I'm trying to say.
你知道我的意思吗？他们想说：“我想演个医生，但得是个古怪的医生”；“我想演个四分卫”，你知道的，当然。我其实没有那种想法，我让事情顺其自然地降临。这就是那个，最高法院以前审理过的那个老案子。他们当时试图给色情制品下个定义。根据最高法院的裁决，色情制品的定义就是“我一眼就能认出来”。他原话字面意思就是这样，你知道的，对。所以只要我看到了，我自然会认出来。我基本上就是把演戏当成色情制品来看待，这就是我想表达的意思。
Sure, right. But acting is the thing that you're interested in pursuing at this moment. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, yeah. Yeah, I'm on the new show, Fall, out or you know that i'm doing season two of that and so we're doing that earlier in the year
当然，对。但演戏确实是你目前有兴趣继续追求的事业。对。对。对。不，对。对，我参演了新剧《辐射》，你知道的，我在拍第二季，所以今年早些时候我们一直在拍那个。
and stuff but like yeah like here's the thing is that you can't get caught in the rat race you know you could win an oscar right right and you're backstage and you're doing the press conference and you're holding your trophy you're the top of your game and you know what they ask you what are you doing next right as if it's not good enough you know and i don't buy into that think about all the people that have won oscar has even been nominated and there's just nothing that comes afterwards it's like that is not that's not the thing it's so and that's that's why i'm asking it's like you couldn't you couldn't ever be more famous than you are now and so it's clearly not fame or money that you're like is it are you interested in literally just playing different people
之类的，但是，对，关键是，你不能陷入这种永无止境的逐利竞争中，你知道的。你可能会赢得一座奥斯卡奖，对吧，然后你站在后台，参加新闻发布会，手里拿着奖杯，你正处于事业的巅峰，而你知道他们会问你什么吗？“你下一步打算做什么？”对吧，就好像这还不够好一样，你知道的，我不买账这一套。想想所有那些赢得过奥斯卡甚至获得提名的人，之后却再也没有任何作品问世，这就说明，这根本不是重点。所以，这就是我为什么要问的原因，就好像你不可能比现在更出名了，所以显然吸引你的不是名气或金钱，而是说，你是不是仅仅对扮演不同的人感兴趣？
like the whole literal thing that an actor does is that interesting to you like are you fascinated by different kinds of people yeah yeah no i i like i like the adventure of calling these different shoes and things like that and um it's something that's kind of like just it comes pretty naturally to me and so forth i mean i i've had a director he was like how could it goes are you doing that on purpose? I'm like, what? He goes, you walk different when I call action.
就像演员要做的字面意义上的那件事，你对这个感兴趣吗？你会被不同类型的人所吸引吗？对，对，不，我，我喜欢穿上这些不同的鞋子去冒险的感觉，而且，这对我来说有点像是，可以说是水到渠成、非常自然的事。我的意思是，我曾遇到过一个导演，他说：“卡尔金，你是故意的吗？”我说：“什么？”他说：“当我喊‘开始’的时候，你连走路的姿势都变了。”
I'm an actor, bro. I just do it. Like, you know what I mean? I don't practice it in the mirror and stuff like that. I kind of like just kind of wrapping myself up in some of these things and kind of just not thinking,
我是个演员，老兄。我只是顺其自然。就像，你知道我的意思吗？我不会在镜子前练习之类的。我差不多就是让自己全身心地投入到这些角色中去，然后就不去多想，
make it reflexive. I looked on your Instagram. I saw that you were in Vegas. Do you like Las Vegas? I love the Vegas. I know, I had to convince Brenda. She was like, oh, I don't like gambling and stuff. I go, no, no, the food's great.
把它弄得带有反思性。我看了你的Instagram。我看到你在维加斯。你喜欢拉斯维加斯吗？我超爱维加斯。我知道，我得说服布伦达。她当时说，哦，我不喜欢赌博之类的。我说，不，不，那里的食物很棒。
And, you know, the shows are cool and stuff. And now I got her at the tables, though. Now she's a blackjack player. It's the best. Is that your game? Yeah, play Blackjack. You know, sometimes I'll throw a little on a roulette and so forth, you know, yeah. But I don't play craps.
而且，你知道，那些演出也很酷什么的。不过现在我已经把她拉上牌桌了。现在她是个二十一点玩家了。这太棒了。那是你的拿手游戏吗？对，玩二十一点。你知道，有时我也会在轮盘上随便投一点注等等，你知道，是的。但我从不玩骰子。
God doesn't play dice, you know, yeah. So neither do I. Sean, if you, I've been to Vegas with Sean before. If you didn't pull him away from the tip, like if Sean happened to be there for a week, he'd lose it all. It's unbelievable his desire to gamble. It's all true. No, Blackjack, it's unreal. I saw him once splitting, splitting aces, blah, blah, blah.
上帝不掷骰子，你知道的，对吧。所以我也不掷。肖恩，如果你，我以前和肖恩一起去过维加斯。如果你不把他从牌桌旁拉开，比如肖恩碰巧在那里待了一个星期，他会把钱全输光。他对赌博的渴望简直难以置信。这都是真的。不，二十一点，太离谱了。我曾看到他分牌，分对A，巴拉巴拉。
And at one point he had, I don't even want to say it was obscene, he'd just come in, yeah, double down, double down, double down, double up, I'm like, dude, what are you doing? Yeah, yeah, well, when you had a few, you just kind of make bad decisions. Yeah, I don't drink when I gamble, that's the trick. I don't think you can win unless you're drunk. That was my problem, yeah. But I do the roulette a lot, and I almost always win
而且一度他手里有，我甚至都不想说是多么荒唐的牌，他刚进来，对，双倍下注，双倍下注，双倍下注，翻倍，我就想，老兄，你在干什么？对，对，好吧，当你喝了点酒的时候，你就会做出一些糟糕的决定。对，我赌博时不喝酒，这就是秘诀。我觉得除非你喝醉了，否则你赢不了。那是我的问题，对。但我经常玩轮盘，而且我几乎总是能赢。
because I just almost bet on every number. You know what I mean? They look for folks like you. You know, what's happened? We'll be right back. And back to the show. What about the sphere? Have you been in the sphere yet?
因为我几乎在每个数字上都下注。你知道我的意思吗？他们就喜欢找你这样的人。你知道，怎么回事？我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。那个“大圆球”（Sphere）怎么样？你去过那个Sphere吗？
Yeah, we saw Backstreet Boys there. My lady was living her best life. She actually, like, she really dressed the part. She looked like a mom that was a big fan of Backstreet Boys. I mean, she was wearing all white with a bandana. She bedazzled her own shirt for it and stuff. Honestly, it was freaking amazing. Like, you know, I was, you know, I was never a Backstreet Boy.
对，我们在那里看过后街男孩（Backstreet Boys）。我太太当时处于她人生的最佳状态。她实际上，呃，她真的很应景地打扮了一番。她看起来就像一个后街男孩的超级妈妈粉。我是说，她穿着一身白衣，还戴着头巾。她甚至自己给衬衫镶上了水钻之类的。说实话，这真是太棒了。就像，你知道，我，你知道，我从来都不是一个后街男孩的
guys and stuff like that but man it was it was actually really great we got to meet the boys and they were that's nice sweet you know i think she wants to go back before the end of the year i think they're doing a christmas like residency too guns to your head mac you got to pick one one of the boys is your favorite oh my god who uh oh who's the fox where there's a gun to his head he's a guy chose one now yeah uh kevin kevin kevin oh yeah but he's a fox Kevin is a fox, yeah. Yes, he is. He was the fox.
粉丝或者类似的人，但是天哪，这真的很棒，我们见到了那些男孩们，他们是——那很好，很甜美，你知道，我想她在年底前还想再去一次，我想他们好像还要办一个圣诞驻场演出。麦克，把枪抵在你头上，你得选一个，这些男孩里谁是你的最爱？噢，天哪，谁，呃，噢，谁是那个帅哥？枪都顶在他头上了，快选一个，现在，对，呃，凯文，凯文，凯文，噢，对，但他是个帅哥。凯文是个帅哥，对。是的，他是。他就是那个帅哥。
Kevin, speaking of Kevin, I'm going to drag it back to Kevin. Yeah, do you know the story that there is a footballer? This is a long tie-in. A footballer who plays professional soccer in Belgium. I believe he plays for Union. There's a professional footballer called Alexis McAllister. He's a midfielder for Liverpool. I love him.
凯文，说到凯文，我要把它扯回凯文身上。对，你知道那个传闻吗，有一个足球运动员？这是一个很长的联系。一个在比利时踢职业足球的足球运动员。我相信他效力于圣吉罗斯联合。有一个叫亚历克西斯·麦卡利斯特的职业足球运动员。他是利物浦的中场。我太爱他了。
He won the World Cup with Argentina. He's incredible. His family is of Irish descent, but they grew up, his great-grandparents moved to Argentina. His brother, Kevin, plays professional as well in Belgium, and he found out when he was 18 that he was named after your character from... No way. Is that true?
他随阿根廷队赢得了世界杯。他太不可思议了。他的家族有爱尔兰血统，但他们是在那里长大的，他的曾祖父母搬到了阿根廷。他的弟弟凯文也在比利时踢职业足球，他18岁时才发现自己是根据你的角色来命名的，来自……不会吧。真的吗？
His name's Karen McAllister. And his name's Kevin McAllister, and his brother plays for Liverpool. I should get his jersey, and I should sign it and send it back to him. Yeah. I got to be so cool. Absolutely. I got to look this up. Yeah, yeah. I got to get that. And I remember watching, because they played Champions League last year randomly Liverpool, and the brothers played each other,
他的名字叫卡伦·麦卡利斯特。他的名字叫凯文·麦卡利斯特，他弟弟为利物浦踢球。我应该搞一件他的球衣，然后我应该签名并寄回给他。对。那一定酷毙了。绝对的。我得查查看。对，对。我得弄一件。我记得我看过，因为他们去年随机踢了欧冠，利物浦，然后两兄弟交手了，
and then the commentator goes, did you know that he found out when he was hating? Was there a time, McCauley, because I've asked this before, and it's happened to me, probably all of us, when you're so identified with somebody like I was with Will and Grace and you with Kevin McAllister,
然后解说员说，你知道他在讨厌的时候才发现的吗？麦考利，有没有那么一段时间，因为我以前问过这事，而且这也发生在我身上，可能我们所有人都有过，当你和某个角色深度绑定时，就像我之于《威尔和格蕾丝》，你之于凯文·麦卡利斯特，
where you fought the attention it brought you for so many years, and then something clicked, you're like, you know what, I need to embrace this thing, and like, it kind of made me who I am. Was there a moment like that? Do you remember?
你对抗它给你带来关注持续了多年，然后突然有什么东西触动了你，你心想，你知道吗，我需要接受这一切，就像，它某种程度上造就了现在的我。有过这样的时刻吗？你还记得吗？
Yeah, I mean, it was definitely burdensome, for sure. and yeah you notice it's the the trick is just relax set up your own ground rules things like that you know realizing that I'm in charge of the social interaction you know like usually when people meet a celebrity they go I'm going to be cool and then they meet it and they just they turn into something else you know right
对，我的意思是，这绝对是个负担，肯定的。然后，是的，你注意到，秘诀就是放松，建立你自己的基本规则，诸如此类的事情，你知道，意识到我是社交互动的掌控者，你知道，就像通常人们遇到名人时，他们会想我要表现得很酷，然后他们遇到了，就变成了另一个人，你知道，对吧
and so it's like it's kind of you know it's like oh I'm I'm in charge I can guide this interaction and also I know I know all kinds of shortcuts and stuff like that like you know just if you want to end it you just go nice to meet you or you know yeah or have a great day or something like that, you know. And a lot of times they walk away before they even realize
所以这就像，你知道，这就像，哦，我，我在掌控全局，我可以引导这种互动，而且我也知道，我知道各种各样的捷径之类的，就像，你知道，如果你想结束它，你只要说很高兴认识你，或者你知道，是的，或者祝你有美好的一天之类的，你知道。很多时候，他们还没意识到
the interaction's over with and like, oh, man, I didn't get that photo. Like, yeah, you sure didn't. Bye. But when you were, when you were, how old were you, did the first home alone? Oh, was nine when I did that. Nine.
互动就已经结束了，然后就会想，哦，天哪，我没拍到那张照片。就像，是的，你确实没拍到。再见。但当你是，当你是，你多大时，拍了第一部《小鬼当家》？哦，我拍那个时九岁。九岁。
So you're nine, you do that movie and you're still, I guess, living at home in New York, right? It's a 35-year anniversary of it, actually. Oh, wow. The Academy Museum later this month, yeah. Oh, wow, that's cool. That's insane.
所以你九岁，拍了那部电影，我想你当时仍然住在纽约的家里，对吧？实际上，这已经是35周年纪念了。哦，哇。本月晚些时候在电影艺术与科学学院博物馆，对。哦，哇，太酷了。这太疯狂了。
Yeah. So you're nine years old, you're super famous, and you're still living at home with your parents and your siblings and everything, I imagine, in New York. But you're the most famous person on the planet walking down the same street. It must have been, that must have been
对。所以你九岁时，你超级有名，我猜你当时仍然和你的父母以及兄弟姐妹们住在纽约的家里。但你是地球上走在同一条街上最有名的人。那一定，那一定
an adjustment. Yeah, it was a lot. I was in like in an old Irish neighborhood and stuff like that. You know, I'm the, you know, I'm an actor. I'm a ballet dancer. I'm all these things. So they're like, hey, what the fuck is this? You know, like that kind of thing. It was a little bit of that. But there was also, yeah. But
是一个适应的过程。对，压力很大。我当时在一个老爱尔兰社区之类的。你知道，我，你知道，我是一个演员。我是一个芭蕾舞演员。我是所有这些。所以他们会说，嘿，这他妈是什么鬼？你知道，就像那种感觉。确实有一点那种情况。但也有，是的。但
yeah, no, it was strange. There was some whiplash. I was shooting my girl in Orlando when the first home alone came out out and, you know, like, yeah, I was kind of an actor, yada, yada, yada, but it wasn't a big deal and then that movie came out and then I just remember the old neighborhood
对，不，这很奇怪。有一种心理落差。第一部《小鬼当家》上映时，我正在奥兰多拍摄《小女孩》，然后，你知道，是的，我算是个演员，诸如此类，但这没什么大不了的，然后那部电影上映了，然后我只记得老社区的
kids, like just of that little community I was living were now peeking through my window. I was like, wait, I know you, you're Jimmy Jim Jim over there, you know, yeah, and it's like, no, all of a sudden it's like, oh, I'm different, I'm not one of them anymore. It was like that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, there was kind of an adjustment period there where, you know,
那些孩子，就我当时生活那个小社区的孩子们，现在正透过我的窗户往里看。我就想，等等，我认识你，你是那边的小吉米，你知道，对，然后就变成，哦，突然间，我变得与众不同了，我不再是他们中的一员了。感觉就像那样。对，对，对，那里有一个适应期，你知道，
and I kind of maneuver those waters as best I could really, you know. I really wasn't given a lot of tools. So it was kind of just, yeah, I kind of just had to embrace it. But for me, everything made sense. You know, you are on a hero's journey. You know what I mean? Oh, you do little black box theater.
我尽我所能地去应对那些情况，真的，你知道。我其实没有被赋予很多工具。所以基本上就是，对，我只能去接受它。但对我来说，一切都说得通。你知道，你正踏上一场英雄之旅。你知道我的意思吗？哦，你出演一些小型黑匣子剧场。
You do smaller movies. You do bigger movies. And then you're a huge fat superstar. That makes sense. That's the hero's journey. And it's not until you have perspective. I go, oh, this is quite abnormal, actually. Like, you know, there's a lot of people who are hacking away at it and they don't get there.
你拍一些小电影。你拍更大的电影。然后你成了一个巨大的超级巨星。这说得通。这就是英雄之旅。直到你有了宏观视角，我才会想，哦，这其实很不正常。就像，你知道，有很多人在努力拼搏却没能到达那个高度。
You know, yeah. Talk a little bit more about that sort of the dichotomy of you are embraced and a part of such a huge global community. You're one of all, the whole world wants to talk to you. But then you have like that moment with your immediate group, your friends, you know, down the block. And there's kind of this thing that eats at you that you're really not one of them. Like they talk to you and about you a little bit differently.
你知道，对。再多谈谈那种二分法吧，你被接纳并成为一个如此庞大的全球社区的一部分。你是所有人中的一员，全世界都想和你对话。但随后你和你身边最亲密的群体，你的朋友，你知道，街区里的那些人，有了那种时刻，有一种东西在折磨着你，让你觉得你真的不是他们中的一员。就像他们对你说话以及谈论你的方式有点不同。
Like when you go back to your regular school or whatever, I remember feeling so lonely and disconnected with that such that, you know, when I had the time and the money to do it, I, like, I overcompensated for trying to get back into that community and just partied like crazy and tried to, like, you know, be one of the guys. Did you go through any of that yourself? Oh, yeah, yeah, I definitely did plenty of partying and so forth, you know, I mean. But in pursuit of that, to try to get back and just be one of the guys?
就像当你回到普通学校或诸如此类的地方时，我记得当时感到无比孤独和脱节，以至于，你知道，当我有了时间和金钱去做这件事时，我，就像，我为了重新融入那个社区而用力过猛，疯狂地参加派对，试图，你知道，成为他们中的一员。你自己经历过这些吗？哦，对，对，我绝对经历过大量的派对之类的，你知道，我的意思是。但为了追求那个，为了试图回去并成为他们中的一员？
Yeah, no, that was, I had a yearning, like I said, I wanted to go to school. You know, it was mostly for social reasons. I wanted to hang out with people my own age. That was a big thing for me. And so I definitely wanted that. But, you know, but it's, you know, it's interesting. It's like, you know, how everyone you're told when you're younger, everyone's a delicate snowflake, you know, everyone's different and stuff like that.
对，不，那是，我有一种渴望，就像我说的，我想去上学。你知道，这主要是出于社交原因。我想和同龄人一起玩。这对我很重要。所以我绝对渴望那个。但是，你知道，但这是，你知道，这很有趣，就像，你知道，当你年轻时每个人都对你说的那样，每个人都是一朵娇嫩的雪花，你知道，每个人都是不同的等等，
I truly felt different, you know, I mean, like, yeah. And rather than looking at it as a burden, it was kind of like, no, I'm a unicorn, you know. Like, yeah, I'm some kind of mythical creature. I am different. And I kind of enjoyed that as well. But at the same time, again, you are kind of alone on an island. You know, you are, you know, again, a peerless person, you know, someone who's an accountant can turn left and right and
我真的觉得自己很特别，你知道，我的意思是，是的。与其把它看作是一种负担，不如说，不，我是一只独角兽，你知道。就像，是的，我是某种神话中的生物。我是不同的。我也挺喜欢这种感觉的。但与此同时，话说回来，你确实有点像孤岛上的一个人。你知道，你，你知道，再次强调，是一个没有同类的人，你知道，一个会计可以向左看右看，
there's other accountants in the office kind of thing. Like, I don't get to have that. But also, like, not only that, and then also there is the, you know, the sort of the commerce of it. Did you appreciate your 9, 10, you're making the deal for the next one? I remember, like, that stuff's like published in the paper about how big it's going to be and all that kind of stuff. Did you, how do you sort of absorb that kind of information when you're 9, 10, 11 years old? I knew I was making some bank. I knew that, but I didn't, you know, you know, you're 9, 10, you're not, I'm not reading, I'm not reading Entertainment Weekly, you know, like, yeah, it's like, you know, I'm watching the new X-Men cartoon, you know, that's what I'm doing, you know, yeah, right, right, right, yeah, trying to find some, you know, you know, normality, you know, in my life and stuff like that.
办公室里有其他会计，诸如此类。我没有这种体验。而且不仅如此，还有，你知道，那种商业层面的东西。你当时感激吗？9岁、10岁时，你在为下一部电影谈合同？我记得，诸如此类的事情都会被登在报纸上，关于它会有多卖座等等。你当时，你9岁、10岁、11岁时是如何吸收这类信息的？我知道我在赚大钱。我知道这一点，但你没有，你知道，你9岁、10岁，你不会，我不看《娱乐周刊》，你知道，就像，是的，就像，我在看新的《X战警》动画片，你知道，这就是我在做的事，你知道，对，对，对，是的，试图在我的生活中找到一些，你知道，正常感，等等。
So I didn't really keep track of it. I was kind of also, I didn't, like, you know, I wasn't told how much I was being paid either. Right, of course. I called it the tiny slip of paper kind of meeting. I turned 18 and I go to. my business manager's office and, you know, boom, he has all my financials and he just slides it across the table and it's like, okay, this is what you got. And I had a sense of how much it was and it was about, you know, it was about right. Yeah. And so, yeah, and also, I'm just very fortunate
所以我并没有真正去追踪这些。我也差不多，我没有，就像，你知道，也没有人告诉我我赚了多少钱。对，当然。我称之为“那张小纸条”式的会议。我满18岁了，我去了
because a lot of people, you know, a lot of kids, they, you know, they work, not just in this business, but all around the world, you know, there's, you know, people working in, you know, diamond mines in Africa, you know, there's, you know, in the slums of Mumbai, they've got nothing to show for it. So I'm, I'm, I wake up very blessed every day knowing that, like, yeah, I came not the other end of the spin cycle. So, so, like, Jason referred to before about, you just seemed so chill and together and, like, you figured it out for yourself, which is great.
我商务经理的办公室，然后，轰，他拿出了我所有的财务报表，他只是把它推过桌子，然后说，好吧，这就是你拥有的。我大概知道有多少，而且，（数字）差不多是对的。是的。所以，是的，而且，我真的非常幸运，
You're in pajamas for Christ's sake. I know, right? Exactly, yeah. I'm on the clock, you know, yeah. So what do you worry about? What's the thing that you worry about? No, you know, I mean, standard stuff. You want to make sure, you know, I raised my boys, right? You know, make sure the lady is, like, you know, happy
因为很多人，你知道，很多孩子，他们，你知道，他们工作，不仅在这个行业，在世界各地，你知道，有，你知道，在非洲的钻石矿里工作的人，你知道，在孟买的贫民窟里，他们一无所有。所以我，我每天醒来都感到非常幸福，因为我知道，是的，我在洗衣机的疯狂旋转中撑到了最后。所以，就像杰森之前提到的，你看起来那么悠闲、淡定，而且，就像你自己把一切都搞定了，这太棒了。
that, you know, that, you know, our cups are full. You know, it's that kind of thing. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, no, it's standard kind of stuff. Because, again, if I never work again, I'm totally fine when it comes to, like, acting or anything like that. Like, you said, every job's my last job. I'm in a constant state of retirement until I'm not, you know, and I retire again. So, yeah, I don't look, my trick is I don't look for satisfaction over there.
你居然穿着睡衣，看在上帝的份上。我懂，对吧？没错，是的。我在上班呢，你知道，是的。那你担心什么？你担心的是什么？不，你知道，我的意思是，标准的事情。你想确保，你知道，我把我的男孩们抚养好，对吧？你知道，确保太太，就像，你知道，快乐，
Yeah, I turn inward when it comes to stuff, you know, both me and my family, you know. What do you do to give, to alleviate the stress? Do you have a, do you have a hobby that brings you great pleasure? that people would be surprised about? Will, you'll like this. I'm a big Lego guy. Really? Yes, I build a lot of Legos.
你知道，我们的生活很充实。你知道，就是那种事情。对，对。对，对，不，这都是标准的事情。因为，话说回来，如果我再也不工作了，就演戏或其他事情而言，我完全没问题。就像你说的，每份工作都是我的最后一在我不再工作之前，我处于一种持续的退休状态，然后我再次退休。所以，是的，我不指望，我的秘诀是我不在那边寻找满足感。
I probably built about 30 sets in the last 40 days. Wow! Yeah, yeah. You know, Lego has, I will say, does have real sort of... Soothing, calming. Yeah, it's like a puzzle.
是的，当遇到事情时，我向内探索，无论是对我自己还是我的家庭，你知道。你做什么来缓解压力？你有没有一个能给你带来极大快乐的爱好？
There's a sort of restorative quality to it, to the soul. You sort things out, you build it piece by piece, you know, you get that release of endorphins when you're done and that sense of accomplishment. I love that. It's therapeutic. It can be really therapeutic and aware. Are you at the level now that, and I am not. In fact, I haven't thought about this until just this moment.
是人们会感到惊讶的？威尔，你会喜欢这个的。我是个超级乐高迷。真的吗？是的，我拼了很多乐高。
Or do you go without the books? Oh, no, no. I still do the books, but I do some of the 10,000 piece sets and stuff like that, too. I clocked myself. I do just under 500 pieces an hour I can do, you know, yeah, like depending on what kind of setting. Lego thing? Yeah, yeah. I'm pretty,
我过去40天里大概拼了30套吧。哇！对，对。你知道，乐高有，我得说，确实有一种真正的……舒缓，平静。对，就像拼图一样。
I'm sick of nature at this point. Yeah, like, do you, yeah, do you have like, a, you're like a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, I just, you know, I, I, I, I can anticipate. If you do it long enough, you can anticipate what they're going to do next. Oh, so, what I sort things and so forth. I want you to try one without the books, one of these things, to one of those, freestyle, you'll see what it looks like, you know?
它对心灵有一种恢复性的品质。你把东西分类，一块一块地拼起来，你知道，当你完成时，你会获得内啡肽的释放和成就感。我喜欢这个。这很有疗愈效果。真的非常具有疗愈作用，而且……你现在达到这种水平了吗？而我没有。事实上，直到刚才这一刻我才想到这个。
Because of that, do you have, like, OCD, because you like to make things, like, complete like that? No, not necessarily. Like, you know, it keeps my mind and my hands busy, you know, and, uh, and, yeah, and also it's, it's decorative and so forth. I love, like, I'll build, like, an Avengers set and then my three and four-year-old just tear it absolutely apart, but it's like that's, but also that's what it's, honestly, I kind of like that's, you know, it's those, um, what is it's like Chinese, like, uh, like vases or whatever, they build them and they smash them and then put them back together, and that's kind of, you know, that's the beauty of it. Do you get annoyed when your boys try to help? no not at all no if anything like they're on like the duplo stuff so it's all the oversized things but i'm really looking forward to building like you know some some proper sets with them and they have helped me i'm like oh give me that red one please and like you know so they're they're gonna super be into it they they love it i i always get them little lego men and things like that those mystery boxes and all that stuff they're super i'm gonna i'm gonna get i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you in touch with them i think that you need to do like a signature build, like design a build for the world, the McCauley-Colkins set.
还是说你不用说明书？哦，不，不。我还是用说明书的，但我也拼一些一万块颗粒以上的套装之类的。我给自己计时。我一小时大概能拼不到500个颗粒，你知道，是的，这取决于是什么样的场景。乐高东西？对，对。我非常……
Oh, yeah, yeah, open up that gateway for me, yeah, for sure. You know, we were just on Fridays and Saturdays on non-school nights. We do slumber parties in Mama-Papa's bed, and let clockwork. They like the Lego movie, but also they're super into Lego Batman. They're super into it. My oldest dressed as Batman this Halloween because he's a big fan of Lego Batman. Oh, that's great. Yeah, and then, yeah, so he was Batman, she was Robin, and I asked him, oh, what do you want me to be?
我这会儿对自然界有点审美疲劳了。对，就像，你，对，你有一个，你是一个，我只是，你知道，我，我，我，我能预料到。如果你拼得够久，你就能预料到他们下一步要做什么。哦，所以，我把东西分类等等。我想让你不看说明书尝试一次，这些东西里的一种，来一次自由拼搭，你会看到它是什么样子的，你知道吗？
He goes, I want you to be a toilet. Wow. Oh, that's right, I saw that. I saw you, you went as a toilet. I was a toilet, yes. That's hilarious. Yeah, but, you know, if your son asks you to be a toilet, you got to be the best thing toilet you can be, you know, yeah. That's hysterical.
因为这个，你是不是有强迫症，因为你喜欢把事情做得像这样完整？不，不一定。就像，你知道，这让我的大脑和双手保持忙碌，你知道，而且，是的，而且它也具有装饰性等等。我喜欢，比如我拼一个复仇者联盟的套装，然后我三四岁的儿子就会把它彻底撕个粉碎，但就像那是，但这也是它的意义所在，说实话，我有点喜欢那种，你知道，这就像那些，呃，是什么来着，就像中国的，呃，像花瓶什么的，人们把它们打破然后重新拼好，而那正是，你知道，那其中的美妙之处。当你的男孩们试图帮忙时，你会生烦吗？不，一点也不。不，如果有的话，他们玩的是得宝（Duplo）系列，所以都是超大号的积木，但我真的很期待和他们一起拼一些，你知道，一些正经的套装，而且他们确实帮过我，我会说，哦，请把那个红色的给我，然后，你知道，所以他们将来一定会超级迷这个，他们超爱这个。我总是给他们买一些乐高小人仔之类的东西，那些神秘盲盒以及所有这些东西，他们超级——我要，我要，我要让你和他们取得联系，我觉得你应该做一个标志性的拼搭作品，为全世界设计一个作品，也就是“麦考利·卡尔金”套装。
See, just for context. Very nice. Ah, that's hilarious. Yeah. How did you do that? Did you make that? Yeah, I just pieced it together with Amazon stuff and everything. that, you know, it's the white crocs really tied the room together,
你看，就当是背景。太棒了。啊，太搞笑了。是啊。你是怎么做到的？这是你做的吗？对，我就是用亚马逊买的东西七拼八凑起来的，你知道的，那双白色的洞洞鞋真的让整个造型有了灵魂，
like Lobowski's rug. I think that if you go as a toilet, you hope that everybody around you doesn't give a shit. Oh, yeah. Well, aren't. I would jump out from behind trees going, poo. I walk by, like,
就像勒博夫斯基的那个地毯。我觉得如果你扮成一个马桶，你就会希望周围所有人都别太当回事。哦，对。没错，要不然。我会从树后面跳出来喊“便便”。我走过去的时候，就像，
if somebody dresses a banana, go, see you later, you know. You know, like, it's like, oh, oh, corn, oh, yeah, I love corn, you know, yeah. And I had a little bag in my bowl and stuff like that, and they, like, oh, I'd be. trick-or-treating. They're like, do you want some candy? Go, oh, no, I just eat poo. And then I would have
如果有人扮成香蕉，就会说，回见啦，你知道的。你知道的，就好像，哦，哦，玉米，哦，耶，我太喜欢玉米了，你知道，对。然后我碗里还带了个小包之类的，他们就会，哦，我会去。要糖。他们会问，你想来点糖果吗？我说，哦，不，我只吃便便。然后我就会准备
a stickers bar ready. Like, oh, I love poo. Like, yeah, kids loved it. I had this one kid who's following me around the entire time all around the neighborhood. You know, yeah. He just loved the fact. He's like, oh, look, it's a walking, talking toilet. Meanwhile, Sean is hiding in his house with the lights off and a sign on the front door
一根士力架。就像，哦，我爱死便便了。就像，是的，孩子们可喜欢了。我有个小孩一直跟着我，在整个街区转悠。你知道，对。他就是喜欢那种感觉。他会说，哦，看啊，一个会走会说的马桶。与此同时，肖恩正躲在家里，关着灯，前门上还贴着个牌子
saying, keep moving. Yeah. That's true. It's so true. No, we know. We know. You've got a house full of candy even when it's not Halloween. And you don't want to share it with the day. Like smog or something. Yeah, totally, yeah. Wow, there you go.
上面写着：继续走，别停留。对。确实如此。千真万确。不，我们懂。我们懂。你家里哪怕不是万圣节也总是堆满了糖果。而且你才不想跟……分享呢。像雾霾什么的。对，完全是，对。哇，你看。
Wait, what's the perfect day with you and your family? I know you just said that slumber thing, which is cool. Yeah, we do slumber party. I really love that. You know, I like taking them to, I'm teaching my boys how to be romantic. So I take them to Trader Joe's and pick out flowers so they can give it to Grandma and Mama and stuff like that. Like, I love doing that kind of stuff.
等等，你和家人完美的一天是怎样的？我知道你刚才说那个睡衣派对，那挺酷的。对，我们办睡衣派对。我真的很喜欢那个。你知道的，我喜欢带他们去，我在教我儿子们怎么变得浪漫。所以我带他们去Trader Joe's（乔氏超市）挑选鲜花，这样他们就能送给奶奶、妈妈之类的人。真的，我超喜欢做这种事。
I like teaching them things. Like, you know, yeah, it's good. But, man, they're at that age. They're running me ragged, like just, you know, do it's like 40 minutes straight of cardio just like, yeah, playing, playing. He's like, you be the bad guy, I'll be the police, and you be the fireman.
我喜欢教他们各种东西。就像，你知道的，嗯，这很好。但是，天哪，他们现在正是那个年纪。他们把我折腾得够呛，就像是，你知道的，连续40分钟的有氧运动，就像，是的，玩啊玩。他会说，你当坏人，我当警察，你当消防员。
He's like, okay, okay. And he's like, oh, man, I'm just like, I'm literally setting fires, you know, so the fireman can put it out, you know, yeah, like that kind of thing. Oh, run a me ragged, but they're that really sweet spot with their, like they are little people now. They have opinions and the way they converse, just being a fly on the wall, it's, it's so cute, you know, yeah.
他会说，好吧，好吧。然后他就说，哦，天哪，我简直就像，我甚至真的在放火，你知道的，好让消防员来灭火，你知道的，对，就那种。哦，把我累得够呛，但他们正处在一个非常美妙的阶段，因为他们现在就像小大人一样。他们有自己的想法，还有他们说话的方式，只要当个旁观者听着，就，就太可爱了，你知道，对。
That's so good. I think grandma taught the boys that, my youngest, who's three, taught them our real names. Oh, it's. So it's like, what's your papa's name? He's like, McCauvey Cokin. And it's like, what's your mother? Bender's strong.
太棒了。我觉得是奶奶教了这几个男孩，我最小的儿子才三岁，教了他们我们的真名。哦，这。所以就像，你爷爷叫什么名字？他会说，麦考利·卡尔金。然后就像，你妈妈是……本德·斯特朗。
I know, that's always kind of fascinating when you learn your parents' names. I thought it was mom and dad, yeah. Well, my oldest, see, my kids, they look at like Sweet Life of Zach and Cody. That was the show that my lady was on when she was a kid. They watched that, and they'll go, oh, that's Mama on TV. I showed them Hobolone, my oldest, especially. He thinks he's Kevin McAllister.
我知道，当你得知父母的名字时，总是觉得挺神奇的。我以前以为就叫爸爸妈妈，对。好吧，我大儿子，你看，我的孩子们，他们看《小查和弟的顶级生活》。那是我太太小时候演的节目。他们看过那个，然后就会说，哦，电视上那个是妈妈。我给他们看《小鬼当家》，特别是老大。他觉得自己就是凯文·麦卡利斯特。
He doesn't put it together. He doesn't put it together. It's me. So he sits there and I'm like, oh, do you remember going down the stairs on the sleazy? He's like, yep, yep, yep, yeah, you remember, you know, sitting up trashed for the bad guy? He's like, yeah, sure, do? I'm like, you liar. You lying liar who lies. That was me.
他没把这联系起来。他没把这联系起来。那是我。所以他坐在那儿，然后我说，哦，你还记得坐着雪橇冲下楼梯吗？他说，对，对，对，对，你记得，你知道的，坐在那儿用杂物戏弄坏人吗？他说，对，当然记得！我说，你这个大话精。你这个满口谎言的骗子。那是我。
Do you like your shoes? That's what paid for your shoes. He's no resemblance between you and the kid in that movie. I love that. He's going to blow his mind in a minute. And one day, I'm waiting for the big reveal where all of a sudden he's just going to go, hey, wait a second. I'm not going to tell him.
你喜欢你的鞋子吗？那可是付了你的鞋钱的。他在那部电影里的那个小孩和你之间完全看不出任何相似之处。我太喜欢这样了。他一会儿就要惊掉下巴了。而且有一天，我正等着那个巨大的揭秘时刻，到时候他突然就会说，嘿，等一下。我可不会告诉他。
I'm sure some kids going to spoil the reveal at school during recess or something like that. But he's going to turn and go, wait, you've been the whole time? Like, yeah, whole time. But, you know, of all the kids on this planet Earth, they're the closest ones who actually say, oh, yeah, I'm like that kid from that movie, you know, yeah. And it's also watching that movie is taking on an entirely different experience now. Like, you know, before it was kind of just, oh, it was a movie that I did. Now it's something I show my kids.
我敢肯定，学校里某个孩子在课间休息时会把这个秘密说漏嘴之类的。但他会转过身去说，等等，你一直都是……？就像，对，一直都是。但是，你知道的，在这星球上的所有孩子里，他们才是最接近那种会说“哦，对，我长得就像电影里那个小孩”的人，你知道，对。而且现在看那部电影也有了完全不同的体验。就像，你知道的，以前它可能只是一种，哦，那是我拍的一部电影。现在它成了我展示给我孩子们看的东西。
And it's a, you know, it's a different animal now. That's really cool. appreciate it differently. It's such a classic holiday movie. Do you, do they like watching it during the holidays? They absolutely love it, yeah. And they still don't know it's you? They still don't know it's me.
而且它，你知道的，现在是个完全不同的概念了。这真的很酷。有了不同的领悟。这真是一部经典的节日电影。你，他们喜欢在节日期间看吗？他们绝对超级喜欢，对。而且他们仍然不知道那是你？他们依然不知道那是我。
That's crazy. Well, I mean, you know, it has been 35 years. Yeah, no, I know, but I'm just like, that's so wild. Yeah, no, it's going to dawn on them. It's going to dawn on them, and it's going to be like, yeah. Like a lot of other parents I showed my kids, they've all seen it a zillion times and love it. Well, they have good taste, yes. Yeah, they've been, it's been a staple.
太疯狂了。好吧，我的意思是，你知道的，毕竟已经过去35年了。对，不，我知道，但我就是觉得，这也太不可思议了。对，不，他们迟早会反应过来的。他们会明白过来的，然后就会觉得，啊。就像许多其他父母一样，我把电影放给孩子们看，他们都看过无数遍并且爱不释手。好吧，他们很有品位，是的。对，这部片子一直都是，一直是必看经典。
Actually, you know, it's funny, I made a video on, uh, I took a photograph of my son from a few weeks ago, and I put it on an AI app, and I gave the prompt to have somebody hand him a golf club, and then he does a golf, does a swing. So he did it. These apps are incredible. So he does this AI-generated video.
其实，你知道，这挺搞笑的，我做了一个视频，呃，我拿了我儿子几周前的一张照片，然后我把它放进一个AI应用里，我给出的提示词是让别人递给他一根高尔夫球杆，然后他做了一个挥杆动作。于是他就做了。这些应用真是太不可思议了。所以他就做出了这个AI生成的视频。
And I show it to him, and he's like, yeah, I remember that. And I go, you never did that. You're liar. Yeah, and I'm like, he's five. And he's like, no, I did that. I'm like, no, you did it. That's it. But I just saw it.
然后我把它拿给他看，他居然说，对，我记得那次。我说，你根本没做过这事。你个大话精。对，然后我就说，他才五岁。他却说，不，我做过。我说，不，是你做的。就是这样。但我刚刚看到了。
Clearly, it's me. Clearly, it's me. Anyway, well, McCauley, Kalken, you, first of all, Zootopia 2, you and Jason. Jason's so in love with your character. Oh, my God. Incredible work. Oh, yeah. You too, man.
很明显那就是我。很明显那就是我。不管怎样，麦考利·卡尔金，你，首先，《疯狂动物城2》，你和杰森。杰森太喜欢你的角色了。哦，天哪。干得太漂亮了。哦，对。你也是，老兄。
You know, yeah. Can't wait to meet you on the carpet. I know. And then the next season of Fallout as well, you can be seen there as well. And McCauley, thank you for joining us, man. You're just an absolute legend. Love us. Yeah, it was fun.
你知道的，对。等不及在红毯上见你了。我懂。然后还有《辐射》的下一季，你也会在里面亮相。麦考利，谢谢你来参加我们的节目，老兄。你绝对是个传奇人物。我们太爱你了。对，这很有趣。
Such a joy. Such a joy. Great having you, pal. Yeah, the great McCauley Calkin, thank you so much, dude. Thanks for being in here. Bye, buddy. See you later. Cheers.
太开心了。太开心了。很高兴你能来，老兄。对，伟大的麦考利·卡尔金，非常感谢你，老兄。谢谢你来到这里。再见，伙计。回见。干杯。
Bye, tutels. Fantastic. I love learning about the, all that stuff. Like, you want to ask him about the home alone, but you're like, can I, shouldn't I? But then you're like, I want to know. So it's pretty, that's so wild. His kids don't know it's him. I know.
再见，各位。太棒了。我喜欢了解，所有这些事情。就像，你想问他关于《小鬼当家》的事，但你又会想，我可以问吗，还是不该问？但接着你又会想，我真的很想知道。所以这真的很，太疯狂了。他的孩子们居然不知道那是他。我知道。
How nuts is that? That's so cool. Wait a minute. Well, like, I want to, he needs to film that moment when they're like, wait a minute that's you um but really cool and like i like how you said jay about how he's um kind of just down to earth figured it out kind of parented himself through the whole thing and came out great it feels very comfortable with himself from where he's at yeah exactly and he's got that uh he's got that that that magic uh sort of indifference right about about about about work and success and all that stuff
这多离谱啊？太酷了。等一下。嗯，就像，我想，他需要把那个时刻拍下来，当他们说“等一下，那是你”的时候，呃，但真的很酷，而且像我喜欢你刚才说的，杰伊，关于他那种，呃，脚踏实地，自己摸索着，靠自己一路当好父母，最后把一切都做得很好，对自己现在所在的状态感到非常自在，对吧，完全没错，而且他有一种，呃，他有那种，那种，那种带有魔力的，某种冷漠感，对吧，对于工作、成功以及所有这些事情的冷漠感，
that'll probably or is it sexy it might be sexy it could be little magic probably just keep him working the rest of his life because he's just got that you know healthy you know the thing about the sexy indifference is it's kind of naughty it is kind of dirty hey did you know what jessie eisenberg can he was can you know a stranger let's get taylor let's get taylor and the gals in here can we get by the way they would love to i mean we'd love to say are they still sleeping let me see oh yeah we just go in the intercom how long is it take to get from one end to your house to the other a while right you have golf carts series of golf carts oh son's doing so well I know he's doing so well.
这可能，或者说这很性感？这可能挺性感的，这可能会带点魔力，大概能让他一辈子都有工作，因为他就是那种，你知道的，健康的，你知道，关于这种性感冷漠感的事情是，它有点淘气，确实有点坏。嘿，你知道杰西·艾森伯格能，他能，你知道一个陌生人，让我们把泰勒和女孩们叫进来吧，我们能把，顺便说一句，她们肯定很乐意，我是说我们很乐意说，她们还在睡觉吗？让我看看，哦，对，我们直接用对讲机。从你家的这一头走到那一头要花多长时间？挺久的吧？你有高尔夫球车吗，有一系列高尔夫球车？哦，儿子表现得真好，我知道他表现得太棒了。
He's really doing it. Hey, so sorry about being late again. Yeah, well, listen, Sean, I'm glad you mentioned that. Do you have a second here? Because Will and I'd love to talk to you about it. Things have been a little sloppy, like, I think, coming out of your, you know, and I'm glad that the audience is not listening to this because, and Will, do you want to start? Yeah, I just said, we, we, we, let me read the thing I wrote.
他真的做得很棒。嘿，非常抱歉又迟到了。对，好吧，听着，肖恩，我很高兴你提到这个。你现在有空吗？因为我和威尔很想跟你聊聊这件事。情况一直有点松散，就像，我觉得，从你的，你知道的，而且我很高兴观众没有在听这个，因为，威尔，你想开始吗？对，我刚说了，我们，我们，让我读一下我写的东西。
Sean, we love you, and we feel like we are losing you. It's okay. Oh, wait, they're all coming in. They're all coming in. Oh, my God. Come on. Here we go. One by one.
肖恩，我们爱着你，我们觉得我们正在失去你。没关系。哦，等等，他们都进来了。他们全进来了。哦，天哪。来吧。我们上。一个接一个。
Where they come. One by one. Amesley. Come on. Name them off. Let's go, Sean. Hi. Oh, my God.
他们从哪儿出来的。一个接一个。艾姆斯利。快来。报一下他们的名字。上吧，肖恩。嗨。哦，天哪。
Look at the, look at the, what are you doing, Sean? I know. This is what. Yeah, we talked about Jesse Eisenberg. Oh, my God. No. He's like really nice. who's
看看，看看，你在干什么，肖恩？我知道。这就是。是的，我们刚才还谈到杰西·艾森伯格。哦，天哪。不。他真的很好。是谁呢？
and wait he's giving his kidney no stranger I know we know we know and what about who doesn't use a phone Ed Sheeran doesn't use a phone and what do we think of that
等等，他还要捐出一个肾吗？不，陌生人。我知道，我们懂，我们懂。还有那个谁从不用手机？艾德·希兰不用手机，对此我们怎么看？
he's so out of touch he's so mysterious well maybe he just needs a smartless mobile plan yeah maybe he needs a smartless mobile plan he said obviously yeah
他太脱节了，太神秘了。好吧，也许他只是需要一个Smartless移动套餐。对，也许他需要一个Smartless移动套餐。他显然是这么认为的，对吧。
Sean sign them up to smartless mobile immediately would you can you hear This is my niece, Elise. Elise, hi, Elise. Say hello. Hello. Hi.
肖恩，立刻给他们订购Smartless移动套餐，好吗？你能听到吗？这是我的侄女爱丽丝。爱丽丝，嗨，爱丽丝。打个招呼吧。你好。嗨。
Hi, oh my God, no, I can't. You know what? Ask them, ask them to say. Yeah, okay, ready? In unison. Okay, ready? Okay, we got to go now. So everybody, we're going to say, one, two, three.
嗨，哦，天哪，不，我不能。你知道吗？让他们，让他们说。对，好吧，准备好了吗？齐声。好吧，准备好了吗？好吧，我们现在得走了。所以大家，我们要说，一，二，三。
Bye. Bye. Hey. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。嘿。Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆杰夫和贝内特·巴比科100%有机手工打造。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。